I find that due to the state of emergency declared by the governor's result of the COVID-19 pandemic and in accordance with House Rule 67 and the governor's emergency order number 12 pursuant to executive order 2020-04, this public body is authorized to meet electronically.
This is a public hearing with the potential for executive session to occur throughout.
Please note that there is no physical location for members of the public to observe and listen contemporaneously to this meeting.
However, in accordance with the emergency order, I am confirming that all members of the committee and select legislative staff have the ability to communicate contemporaneously during this meeting through the Zoom electronic meeting platform.
And the public has access to contemporaneously listen and if necessary participate in this meeting by the Zoom platform or by telephone.
All necessary access information has been made available in the House calendar and through the electronic calendar on the General Court website.
The notice for this meeting notice complies with House rules and RSA 91-A.
Anyone who has a problem accessing the meeting should call 271-3600 or email hcs at legislative.state.newhampshire.us.
In the event the public is unable to access the meeting, the meeting will be adjourned and rescheduled.
Is Brett?
Yes, he is.
I want to introduce the staff that are on the meeting assisting us, Brad Greenland, committee researchers.
Please note that all votes that are taken during this meeting shall be done by roll call vote.
We'll now start by taking a roll call of attendance.
And when each member states their presence, please also state whether there is anyone in a room with you during this meeting, which is required under the right to know law.
Clerk, you can call the roll.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I can chair Gagne.
Here.
Clerk is here.
Representative Smith.
Representative Hill.
Representative Arendt.
Present and in the committee room.
Good morning.
Representative Ankerberg.
He just locked in.
Yep, present in my house alone.
Thank you.
Representative Gorski?
Present.
I'm in my office, but my wife's in the house walking about.
Thank you.
Representative Representative O'Pair?
Present.
I'm in my office alone.
Representative Patero?
Representative Sykes?
I'm here in the kitchen alone at my home.
Thank you.
Representative Cleaver?
Present and I am alone.
Representative Fenton.
I am present.
I am at my house and I'm happy to announce I am home.
My wife is in the room with our newborn son.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Representative Pickering.
Here, home alone.
Representative Rich.
Thank you.
That's Representative Newman.
Thank you for that information.
Representative Newman.
I'm here and my wife, Representative Newman, may be, she's in the house and may enter the room occasionally.
Thank you.
Representative Talersky.
I'm here.
I'm in my home with my husband and two sons who are also working today.
Thank you.
Representative Fox.
I am here at home.
My husband is in the house and he's in and out of the room, but not observing the session.
Thank you.
And Representative Stevens.
Here, home, no one in the room.
Thank you.
And Representative Deayu.
I am here in my office alone, but there are others in the house.
Thank you.
And Tom is out for the moment.
Yep.
Right?
Okay, so we have...
Do you need to vote?
Do you need to come in here?
No, I couldn't get enough of that.
Okay, who's going to introduce this?
Representative Marsh, is he on?
Okay.
Okay, I will introduce House Bill 78.
And speaker, Representative Marsh, are you around?
Okay, Representative Crawford will introduce the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm introducing House Bill 78 relative to certificates of title and driver's licenses for members of the United States Foreign Service.
And would you like to speak on the bill?
I believe that Mr.
Anderson should be here to speak to the bill.
Okay, member of the public, Eric Anderson?
Yeah, he's here.
One second, please.
Okay.
Can everybody hear me all right?
I'm about three inches from this mic.
I can hear you very well.
Thank you.
Look good in that chair, Representative Gagney.
On my birthday yet.
Oh, happy birthday.
Double sevens.
Double vote.
Good morning.
Can everyone hear me okay?
Is that it?
All right.
Well, thank you so much to the Transportation Committee for today and thank you to Deputy and Representatives Marsh, Crawford, and Nelson for co-sponsoring this bill.
My name is Eric Anderson.
I also believe my colleague David Mulkey is also online and has some brief prepared remarks also to share with you should you be amenable to that.
My testimony reflects my own views today and not those of the U.S.
government.
In 2008, the U.S.
Department of State hired me and I deployed on orders from Madison to Washington, D.C.
for brief training and then onward to an overseas assignment.
I have served as a Peace Corps volunteer in Romania and as a diplomat in Suriname, Russia, and Thailand, and I will deploy to Afghanistan this summer when I will be separated from my wife, beloved hound mix rescue dog, and two young children, including like Representative Donovan, a baby girl that we had born just eight days ago.
I am fiercely proud of our country, but perhaps even more so of our Granite State, having been born and conquered, raised in Amherst, graduated from public high school in Moultonboro, and even having a certain aversion to sales taxation.
My siblings and their families live in Moultonboro and my mom in Madison.
I visit as much as I can and had we not just had our baby girl, I would almost certainly be participating in the Great Meredith Rotary Ice Fishing Derby this weekend.
I truly look forward to the day when I can eventually return home for good.
I'm here today to request your support for House Bill 78.
The bill's common sense tweaks will resolve residency and driver's license renewal challenges uniquely associated with service to country by members of the U.S.
Foreign Service from the state of New Hampshire, like myself.
One, the bill will allow New Hampshire foreign service professionals to maintain and renew their New Hampshire driver's licenses while deployed overseas.
As the president of the American Foreign Service Association, former Ambassador Eric Rubin, wrote in a letter expressing support for this House Bill 78 to this committee, this is actually one of the biggest challenges cited by the organization's 16,000 plus members.
The license renewal process can have certain residency requirements that are difficult, if not impossible, to maintain simply because of our long-term active duty deployments outside of New Hampshire.
Two, this bill would allow New Hampshire residents to convert out-of-state driver's licenses to New Hampshire driver's licenses when they deploy from a domestic assignment outside of New Hampshire to an overseas location.
This is critically important because New Hampshire foreign service professionals who are legitimately from New Hampshire and deploy overseas, are also likely to deploy from overseas locations to duty stations throughout the United States, most of which are unfortunately outside of New Hampshire.
During those domestic deployments, and unlike our military colleagues, we are frequently compelled to convert our New Hampshire driver's licenses to the licenses of the states to which we are assigned and temporarily reside on active duty.
But after such domestic deployments conclude, we typically redeploy overseas again.
And here's the specific problem this would fix.
New Hampshire foreign service professionals in this situation will be able to convert that out-of-state driver's license back home to a New Hampshire driver's license.
Bluntly, non-New Hampshire states should not be able to keep us New Hampshire foreign service professionals on their books indefinitely just because we happen to be in their state on a two or three-year deployment on active duty.
In 2013, for example, the State Department assigned me to Washington DC for Moscow.
At that time, I had to convert my New Hampshire driver's license to a DC driver's license in order to register a car.
But upon subsequent redeployment from DC back overseas, I struggled to convert my DC driver's license back home to a New Hampshire driver's license because I did not have a New Hampshire lease, mortgage, or utility bills.
New Hampshire military colleagues in this scenario would have simply retained their New Hampshire driver's license throughout all domestic and overseas assignments.
This is required for the Service Members Civil Relief Act, a federal law that thankfully shields our military colleagues from these administrative challenges and grants numerous protections to our military colleagues who are frequently uprooting their lives in service to our nation.
Unfortunately, this law, however, does not extend to the Foreign Service.
Like the Uniformed Service, though, the Foreign Service also deploys frequently in service to nation.
And in some deployments, we face physical dangers, as the tragic loss of life in Libya, Kenya, South Sudan, Vietnam, and 61 other countries remind us.
In fact, about one-third of the active duty Foreign Service has served in a dangerous unaccompanied assignment, according to the American Foreign Service Association.
The third fix this bill would enable is it would allow new New Hampshire spouses to acquire New Hampshire driver's licenses when marrying a New Hampshire resident on federal deployment.
My colleague David Mulkey will describe this challenge in greater detail in his testimony.
In short, House Bill 78 will enable foreign service professionals hired from New Hampshire, diplomats, international development professionals, and intelligence experts to preserve their legitimate connections to their home state of New Hampshire that they otherwise struggle to maintain.
It's an honor to serve the United States and the people of New Hampshire, and I hope you will support House Bill 78.
Thank you so much for your consideration.
Thank you for your testimony, Mr.
Anderson.
Any questions for the witness?
You'll have to help me.
Yes, definitely.
Go ahead.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Mr.
Anderson, for answering my question.
It really is just, do you have a written testimony that you can send to the clerk?
I do have written testimony.
To be honest, we had a clearance process with the U.S.
Department of State regarding our personal testimony using personal time and resources.
When it's published, that requires an additional review.
So let me, if it's okay, let me just double check that review process, make sure I'm complying with the government's rules and regulations.
And once I get their clearance, I can go ahead and send that to the committee if that works okay.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you so much, Mr.
Anderson, for your testimony this morning.
My question is, can you hear me, first of all?
Yes, I can.
Okay, good enough.
I just want to make sure our microphones are working.
So I'm interested to know, is there such a thing as universal driver's licenses?
Because I recall there used to be, and I don't know if that would apply here.
I am not aware of a universal federal driver's license of any kind.
Perhaps what you might be thinking of is an international driver's license.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So there are, I'm not an expert on those that's maintained.
I'm not exactly sure how that works, but there are international driver's licenses.
I did have one in my first deployment to Suriname for one year because I anticipated difficulty getting a local Surinamese driver's license.
And if I recall correctly, it's valid for just one year.
It's a relatively short duration.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Representative Sykes, I believe.
Yeah.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I actually changed my mind.
I've withdrawn my raised hand.
Thank you.
Okay.
Anyone else?
Seeing none.
Thank you.
Excuse me, Mr.
Chairman.
My hand has been up.
I apologize for interrupting.
I can hardly see that little yellow hand because this thing ain't working.
Okay.
Go ahead, Representative.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mr.
Anderson, for laying out your need.
I have family who served in the Foreign Service and we're all over the place, so I understand the challenges.
I am just curious if I'm looking at the verbiage here, a New Hampshire resident deployed on federal orders.
you mentioned in passing the foreign service the peace corps would this apply to contractors is there a need for any more definition on who this applies to?
The vision in federal orders is that it would apply to any American citizen deployed on behalf of our nation overseas.
There are contractors who can deploy overseas, but I do not believe this would apply to them because our travel orders are cut by the U.S.
government.
So when I deployed to Afghanistan, the U.S.
Department of State will cut travel orders for me.
For contractors, their companies are responsible for their travel, even though they're working for the U.S.
government.
I'm not an expert in sort of employment of contractors, but my understanding is the way the language is written is that it would apply to American citizens working on behalf of the U.S.
government deploying overseas, basically in a civilian capacity.
It would apply to any civilians.
So, you know, in Bangkok, my last assignment, I worked very closely with our CDC colleagues.
And so it would apply to them, for example, they're, you know, deployed overseas there.
Any American outside of the military that doesn't have that service members civil relief protection, this would extend to.
Basically, this is a fix because the federal protection of the federal, the service members civil relief act doesn't apply to civilians deploying overseas.
So this is kind of almost a stopgap to help resolve some of the challenges that we face.
Did I answer your question sufficiently?
I think so.
Thank you.
Anyone else wish to ask a question of this witness?
Thank you, Mr.
Anderson, for your testimony.
Thank you so much.
And just to note, my first name is Eric, but my son frequently uses this computer, and I just noticed his name is displayed here, so apologies.
Okay, thank you, sir.
Forgive me for mispronouncing your name, Mr.
David Moki.
Are you there, sir?
I know.
Hello.
Can everybody hear me?
This is David.
Yes, sir.
Could you pronounce your last name for me?
Sure.
My name is David Mulkey.
You got it just about right.
Thank you so much.
You're sideways.
Well, there we go.
I am halfway across the world.
Yes, you are.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I want to echo the thanks given to Representatives Marsh, Crawford and Nelson and Deputy Speaker Smith for their support of this bill.
Like my colleague Eric, I believe this proposed legislation will make a meaningful difference in the lives of Foreign Service members and their spouses, such as me and my wife.
My name is David Mulkey.
I am a Foreign Service officer with the U.S.
Department of State, and I was hired out of Woodstock, New Hampshire 15 years ago.
Since then, the Department of State has assigned me to China, to Greece, to Iraq, to Vietnam, and now where I am in Thailand.
I met my wife at church when I was in Washington, D.C.
during a temporary assignment about 11 years ago, and life has happened.
I'm blessed with two young kids now, two adopted street dogs, one from Hanoi, one from Bangkok.
Nearly every time we go back to the United States, we return to New Hampshire.
My domicile is in New Hampshire.
I vote in New Hampshire.
I'm also deeply proud of my family legacy, both in New Hampshire, but also serving our nation overseas.
My grandparents settled in Guilford in the 1950s, and they set up the Mulkey family Christmas tree farm, which still operates today.
My father spent three decades in the Foreign Service, including two tours in Vietnam during the war.
I have uncles who served 12 and 30 years in the Navy, an aunt who spent years in the Peace Corps and is an educator in Sub-Saharan Africa.
We are all New Hampshire residents, and I really hope my two children can follow in our footsteps too and represent both New Hampshire and the United States to the rest of the world.
Now, I have had a New Hampshire's driver's license for my entire adult life.
I learned to drive the New Hampshire way, not the way of some of our neighboring states.
Renewing my license hasn't always been easy from overseas, though.
I remember one year arriving home from Athens late on Christmas Eve, then going up to Woodstock to celebrate Christmas Day with my family, and then rushing on the 26th the next day to the DMV to get a renewal, and then flying back out not long after.
I have, by the way, been very grateful for the customer service at the DMVs in Concord and especially in the Tamworth offices over the decades.
But I know many of my Foreign Service colleagues from New Hampshire have trouble renewing their New Hampshire licenses from out of state.
This is a challenge, especially as my colleague Eric mentioned, when we're assigned to do temporary tours in Washington, D.C.
or domestically.
Many Foreign Service officers have to get a driver's license temporarily from not just D.C., but maybe Virginia or Maryland to be able to have a car there.
But we really have no intention of settling in those places in the long term.
As Eric mentioned, our military colleagues have special rights to maintain their home state licenses, even when assigned elsewhere domestically.
It makes a lot of sense.
Our military colleagues are uprooted often.
They're assigned by the DOD all over the world and all over the United States.
It's a common sense provision that allows military members to maintain those important home ties that a driver's license can symbolically represent.
We Foreign Service members also uproot our lives often, typically every one, two, or three years, but federal law doesn't yet provide us a similar benefit.
That's why this proposed legislation is so important to members of the Foreign Service from New Hampshire.
In addition, this proposed legislation would make an important fix to allow spouses to acquire a New Hampshire driver's license when marrying a New Hampshire Foreign Service resident on federal deployment at a state.
For example, since I married my wife, we've been assigned to Hanoi, to Bangkok, and a temporary Washington, D.C.
tour.
As much as we would have liked to spend some of these years living in New Hampshire, the Foreign Service had other ideas and sent us elsewhere.
So it's been challenging for my wife to meet current New Hampshire residency requirements to get a New Hampshire driver's license, despite her and my whole family's intention to keep our residency ties to New Hampshire well into the future.
Currently, for example, my wife has a Virginia driver's license that will expire in a couple of months.
We don't want to renew a Virginia driver's license.
We don't have property there or any real ties there, but she's also not eligible to apply for New Hampshire driver's license from here in Bangkok.
This proposed legislation would make a practical difference in my wife's ability, my family's ability to strengthen and maintain these New Hampshire ties.
So to sum up, I believe that House Bill 78 would allow foreign service professionals from New Hampshire, diplomats, development experts, diplomatic security law enforcement officers to preserve and renew our connections to this great state and to our fellow New Hampshire residents.
And as our families grow, we'll be able to help our loved ones forge connections to New Hampshire as well, even if we spend much of our time on overseas mission.
So thank you once again for your consideration.
Thank you, Mr.
Mulkey.
Will you take questions?
Sure, I'd be happy to.
Representative Aaron?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Moke, for your testimony this morning.
In your story, in your testimony regarding your wife, where is her residency established now?
She is a registered New Hampshire voter.
And so she is a New Hampshire resident, or I think the technical term is domicile.
I think that's the tax and legal term.
So she is a New Hampshire domicile, a New Hampshire resident.
So, a follow-up?
Yes.
Thank you.
So as a result of that residency, she's been unable to obtain a New Hampshire driver's license?
That's correct, because my understanding of the current procedures is that you have to show things like a utility bill or multiple pay stubs going to a New Hampshire address, documentation of that nature to get a New Hampshire's driver's license.
And unfortunately, since we're living in Bangkok, Thailand, we aren't able to fulfill those specific requirements from overseas.
I'll work.
One more follow-up.
Thank you.
So I guess I'm confused then.
How was she able to get ability to vote in New Hampshire if she has no other way to show residency?
I am not an expert on how voter registration laws work in New Hampshire versus the driver's license laws.
But what we did in this last election is we followed the voter registration form to the T.
I was already registered to vote.
And for my wife, she registered to vote for the first time in New Hampshire.
And based on the form, I believe we fulfilled all the criteria for my wife.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Any other questions for the witness?
Seeing none, I have one question for you, sir.
What time is it there in Bangkok?
It's pretty late.
It's almost 9 9 30 p.m thank you brings back memories for me thank you any other questions uh any other uh people who have not signed up who wish to speak yes you have one in the queue.
Hold on one second.
It's Elizabeth.
Can't pronounce her last name.
Sorry.
It's the director.
Oh, is this a DMV director?
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, put her on.
She's on.
Morning, Mr.
Chairman, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Good morning again, and happy birthday, and good morning, members of the committee.
Thank you for allowing me some time to speak.
I did sign up in opposition to the bill, and I'm only opposing the bill in the way it is written, and I'm happy to work with the sponsors on improving the language of it.
I oppose for several reasons.
And one of them is just some technical defects of the bill.
If I could bring your attention to paragraph two, which is a paragraph that both Mr.
Anderson and Mr.
Milkey talked about, where the intent would be to allow spouses to opt into a New Hampshire license while residing at a place outside of New Hampshire.
I am not sure how logistically we could make that happen because we really need an individual who has not been licensed in New Hampshire to be present to have their photograph taken at the DMV.
So if the intent of that is to apply for a New Hampshire license remotely or through the mail, we simply wouldn't be able to issue a license without a photograph and the individual present for that.
So that's section two of the bill.
Under section three of the bill, the current language allows federal employees assigned to a location outside of the United States or the spouses of those employees to maintain New Hampshire residency.
The new language that is added speaks to the conversion of an out-of-state license back to a New Hampshire license during such deployment, and I believe Mr.
Anderson also spoke about the logistics of that.
A couple of questions that we would have on that.
I think what the new language contemplates is someone deploys overseas, returns to a domestic post that's outside of the state of New Hampshire, then redeploys outside of the country, and is looking to then convert an out-of-state license back to a New Hampshire license.
So again, we would be looking for an application for a new license.
The question would be what type of documentation we would require to prove the deployment back and forth.
And my biggest concern with that would be the time frame.
Again, how long would we allow for a conversion of a license to occur?
As long as we have a photo on file, that photo could be dated.
So perhaps contemplating a time frame during which we could make that conversion.
And really, it would be an application for a new license, because that point when you convert your new hampshire license to an out-of-state license you are required to turn in your new hampshire license and you're issued a different state license so with this process of conversion we would be looking to also retain the out-of-state license and issue a new new hampshire license i'll pause right there and see if the committee members have any questions for me.
Thank you, Director.
Any questions for Director Malicki?
Well, I have a lot in my head.
I can pause for a minute.
No, that's okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
Go ahead, Representative.
I can pause for a minute.
No, that's okay.
Go ahead, Representative.
Mr.
Chair, thank you, Director Bilecki.
This is Representative Crawford.
I know we had conversations on this bill, and when it was written, I wasn't totally pleased with what was here, and I hope that we could work together to find some type of amendment that would work for you and work for Mr.
Anderson and his colleagues.
The problem that they're having is when they come back to the United States, they have to register their vehicles.
So they have to give up their New Hampshire license and get like a Washington, D.C.
license in order to do that.
And they're in the country for a short period of time until they're deployed again.
With the military, they don't have to do that.
Can you think of something just off the top of your head right now that could help them with that, or maybe we should just work together on trying to find a solution?
Thank you for the question, Representative Crawford, and I apologize for not being able to get back to you and really raise all of the concern.
I know the bill has changed a little bit from the time that we've spoken about it.
I'm happy to collaborate with you and Mr.
Anderson on the language that would work for us.
Again, I'm not sure how we can find a way to fit the need for the spouses where they've never held a New Hampshire license to be able to issue one.
So section two of the bill, I really am not sure how we can accomplish that.
With section three and the conversion of that, again, I think we could introduce language that allows those that are deployed outside of the United States to not have to reprove their residency.
Although I do want to say that in order to prove New Hampshire residency, sure, their property tax bills and other things, but we also would accept a notarized letter from a New Hampshire property owner that states that the individual maintains the residency at their address as well.
So there are other ways to prove New Hampshire residency outside of providing tax bills or vehicle titles or other things of proof of property ownership in New Hampshire.
So I think section three, we could look to come up with some compromised language as well.
My concern is the timeframe for which we would leave that conversion option open or application for New Hampshire license open because again, it's just the age of that photograph that we have on file.
And at which point do we have an opportunity to update that?
Representative Fenton, do you have your hand up?
No, I don't.
Okay, Representative Aaron?
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you for your testimony, Ms.
Belicki.
I'm interested to know what kind of know whether we do have a capability of having any kind of acceptance of international driver's license.
Is there such a thing still?
Thank you for your question, Representative Aaron.
we really don't New Hampshire DMV doesn't get involved in the international driver's license it's really more from an enforcement perspective so if you have Erin, we really don't, New Hampshire DMV doesn't get involved in the international driver's license.
It's really more from an enforcement perspective.
So if you have an individual who's driving on New Hampshire roadways with an international driver's license, they really would just have potential interactions with law enforcement where those licenses would be acceptable for the duration of their stay in New Hampshire or the country.
Okay, thank you very much.
Sure.
Representative Tulerski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Director Bielecki.
Can you advise us on what the process is for the military?
If you have a New Hampshire resident with a New Hampshire license deployed in the military and they marry and the spouse wants to acquire a New Hampshire license, is there a process in place for that?
Yes, thank you for the question, Representative Talurski.
As Mr.
Anderson has testified, the military members themselves don't have to give up their New Hampshire license, and even if they're deployed, they can renew their New Hampshire license either online or through the mail.
Spouses of those military members would have to obtain their initial New Hampshire license through an in-person appointment as well, Because again, in order to issue a license, we need to take a photo of that individual.
Proving residency is a bit more lenient because again, they retain their residency just like the military members do.
Thank you very much.
Any other questions for the director?
Seeing none, any other people out there who wish to testify who are not on the list?
Hold on.
Representative Sykes has his hand up.
Yeah, Representative Sykes, go ahead.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just want to echo the clerk's comments that I would like to see her and the other sponsors of this bill get together with DMV to see if there can be an amendment introduced that will achieve the purposes of making driver's licenses more readily available to members of the foreign diplomatic corps.
Chair agrees.
Representative Crawford.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman.
Director Berlecki, are you still on?
Yes, I am, Representative Crawford.
Do you have any written testimony to send to me on this bill?
I don't, but I can summarize it and send it to you.
That would be wonderful.
Thank you so much.
Sure.
Thank you.
Okay.
Seeing no more questions, I will close House Bill 78.
And for the record, three opposed to this bill.
And seven supporters of this bill.
No, let me rephrase that.
No, two opposed.
Two opposed.
Yeah, seven support.
Mr.
Chairman, may I ask a quick question before we move on?
I've already closed it.
It's not about that bill, sir.
Okay, go ahead.
And I don't know if we could ask Chairman Walsh when he returns.
I'm just curious, when we're all in the LOB and there are members of the public following along with the hearing, and we see someone from a department sitting in the audience who could possibly contribute and answer a question, and we'll often make eye contact or the chair will ask if, say, Director Bielecki could answer a question.
Are we allowed to inquire if someone's in the zoom waiting room?
If they could please answer questions from say state police or DMV, even though they haven't signed up to testify?
Yes.
Thank you., everybody.
Just give me a minute to reset.
We'll go right into our next hearing.ありがとうございました Thank you.
Okay.
We've been open a public hearing on House Bill 329, an act relative to storage rail cars containing hazardous materials.
The sponsor is Representative Thompson.
Is he signed on?
I don't have my screen up.
See everybody.
I just promoted them.
Good morning, representative.
Can you hear us?
Yes, I can.
The floor is yours.
Good morning, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
I'm Representative Dennis Thompson of Stewartstown, New Hampshire, representing Coas County District 1.
I'm a Republican and sponsor of House Bill 329.
So I've put forward in the bill, this would control storage and passage of cars, railroad cars, basically tank cars containing hazardous materials as described by the Federal Railway Safety Act.
Specifically, in the north country, in the towns of North Stratford and Columbia, we have a lot of these cars on a state-owned siding which has been leased to the New Hampshire Central Railroad.
They've been there over a period of time.
I will tell you that in the last two days there's been a dramatic movement of these cars that have been stored up here for months.
we assume but do not know that they are either full or empty um these cars that have been stored up here for months.
We assume but do not know that they are either full or empty.
House Bill 329 addresses that in requiring, in addition to the placarding which the federal government requires, which describes the contents of any of these cars.
The only way the public would know would be if they looked it up online or had a hazardous placards manual available to them.
I've requested that the cars be placarded with full or empty stickers with signage.
A fairly simple thing to do either with a sticker or a cardboard sign that could be removed if the cars leave the storage area and go on rail.
It does allow for a 72-hour storage of cars that are part of a gathering train, term used by the railroad.
It would limit the storage of these cars within 1,500 feet of an occupied dwelling or 1,500 feet of a traveled way.
I submitted testimony and some photographs.
I don't know if the committees received them, but many of these cars recently have been stored within 35 to 50 feet of occupied residences.
Some of these residents are concerned.
They don't know if the proper precautions have been taken to protect them from the materials in the cars.
And unless evidence to the contrary is presented, we just don't know.
It's basically a very short bill.
It requires the things that I've, I've, uh, I've listed.
Um, the exceptions are if the cars are coming in to be delivered to a commercial or industrial, um, user in New Hampshire, they'd be exempt.
Um, as long as they're, there for that reason If they're going to a propane storage facility that's licensed by whatever agency would license those, they'd be exempt as well as home heating oil, biodiesel, any of those.
Biodiesel, incidentallyally is not a hazardous material.
I believe that's about it.
If you have any questions, I'd be willing to answer them.
Thank you, sir.
Any questions from the committee?
Representative Gorski?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Representative Thompson for taking my question.
You mentioned in your bill that you want a placard which states, you know, full or empty as well as the contents.
My question is, who would be responsible for doing that posting of those signs?
My feeling would be that it would be the railroad, the local or national railroad that handles the cars and puts them into storage and takes them back out.
And a follow-up question, Mr.
Chairman?
Yep, for follow-up.
And if they don't, what's your idea that if, let's say, the local railway doesn't do it, is there going to be an imposed penalty if they don't post a placard or signs on them?
This bill has been added under Section 18 of RSA 21P, which is an RSA that gives the state some authority to enforce general safety regulations throughout the transportation industry.
And whatever the penalties would be under that, I do not know.
Okay.
Thank you, Representative Thompson.
Any further questions from the committee?
I whatever the penalties would be under that I do not know.
Okay, thank you representative Thompson.
Any further questions from the committee?
Yes.
Representative Aaron.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Representative Thomas.
I have a question regarding what is your concern about any rail cars that had previous contents or are empty?
Why would that be a concern with regard to, say, propane or heating oil?
Can you explain that?
My specific concern is with propane.
Heating oil is, although flammable, is not necessarily explosive.
Although I understand any real cars containing these type of materials, if exposed to a sufficient amount of heat, could blev is the term used when a railroad car explodes.
You may be familiar with, in 2013, July of 2013, in Lake McGonagall, Quebec, there was a train that got loose from the braking system, subsequently went seven miles downhill on a track and exploded.
That carried crude oil, and crude oil is probably the least offensive of the flammable and explosive oils.
But the result in that event that event was 47 people were killed 2 000 people were displaced from their homes and businesses and the majority of the downtown of lake mganic quebec was destroyed in fire and as to this day not really been ever recovered from it.
In the case I'm stating in my district, these cars appear to be all propane.
And I understand from the research I've done that even when you empty one of these cars, there is up to 250 or 300 gallons of liquid material left in the car.
when you leave a gaseous liquid gas in an open space like that, and it's not open, it's confined in the car, but the liquid material then becomes gaseous.
At that point, if the car were impinged and there were sparks involved hit by a tractor trailer or whatever, the car would be as explosive as it would be if it was full of liquid.
The liquid is more stable than the gaseous material is, is my understanding.
Follow up.
Thank you for that.
And I also have a question as to whether there's ever been a problem or incident in New Hampshire with these rail cars.
Not that I'm aware of now.
Thank you.
Okay.
Any further questions from the committee?
I see Representative Cleaver.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you for taking the question.
Do you know if this is covered under the National Transportation Act or the Federal Department of Transportation?
There is some coverage under the Federal Rail Act, but there is also under 49 U.S.C.
201-06, there's an exception.
And if I may, I'd read it to you.
It's just a paragraph long.
It says a state may adopt or continue to enforce a law, regulation, or order covering the same subject matter as a DOT regulation.
when an additional or more stringent law, regulation, or order is necessary to eliminate or reduce an essentially local safety or security hazard, is not compatible with law, regulation, or order of the United States and does not unreasonably burden interstate commerce.
I think that these situations, and I understand we have them up here, we have them in, have or have had them in Walpole, as well as in the Lebanon area, and possibly other places in the state.
So I think that this bill is not overreaching the federal, it is maybe overreaching the federal regulation because we're trying to protect the local hazard or prevent the local hazard.
All set.
Okay.
I have the questions from the committee.
Please keep in mind, we've got several other people signed up to testify and we better make up a little time.
Seeing none, thank you very much, Representative.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Next up,'ve got Christopher Wagner representing Marigas Propane in opposition he signed up to speak for three minutes Mr.
Wagner you've got the floor for three minutes he just he's on mute.
Oh wait, there he goes.
Mr.
Wagner.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Mr.
Chairman and esteemed members of the House Transportation Committee.
My name is Christopher Wagner.
I serve as the Director of Compliance and Regulatory Affairs for Amerigas Propane LP and am honored for the opportunity to testify before the committee on their behalf today.
Amerigas opposes House Bill 329 and respectfully asks the committee to vote no.
I have submitted a detailed written testimony in advance of this hearing and intend to supplement that with a brief statement.
Amerigas is the largest propane retailer in the United States, serving over 1.5 million customers in all 50 states.
In the service of our customers, we distribute approximately 1.1 billion gallons of propane annually, with over 21.5 million of that being distributed in New Hampshire.
The state of New Hampshire supply needs are highly reliant on the transportation of LP gas by rail.
It is also important to recognize that over 70 percent of the volume delivered within the state occurs between the months of October and March, which makes effective staging of resources critical.
The rail industry is not immune to delays or stoppages.
This can affect the supply chain and ultimately the residents of New Hampshire.
It is also for this reason that effective supply chain management and staging of resources is so critical.
Imposing the restrictions proposed in this bill on this critical supply chain resource increases the risk of supply outages and increases the vulnerability of the supply chain during the coldest months of the year and during inclement weather periods, precisely when New Hampshire's propane customers need security and supply the most.
Propane is a critical resource to the state of New Hampshire for heat, hot water, cooking, backup power for our schools, healthcare facilities, emergency responders, and even cellular communications.
For these and many other reasons, we respectfully request that the committee vote no on House Bill 329.
Mr.
Chairman and esteemed members of the House Transportation Committee, I thank you for the opportunity to testify before you today and would be happy to answer any questions.
Thank you, sir.
Any questions?
Representative Adam?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you, Mr.
Wagner, for coming to testify.
I'm interested to know, between the months of October and March, it's basically colder weather.
So can you tell me the difference in perhaps the level of danger or volatility that propane may pose in being stored in rail cars in New Hampshire in those months?
Thank you for your question, Representative Aaron.
Vapor pressures are completely dependent on external temperature.
So the atmospheric temperature at any particular moment impacts the vapor pressures within a propane rail car or bulk storage tank.
In that, we expect to have far lower vapor pressures within a rail car during those colder months of the year.
There are safety devices that are built into and integrated into rail cars that allow that rail car to measure and adapt to interior pressures.
But at that point in the season, there's relatively no internal pressures within those rail cars or extremely limited internal pressures within those rail cars, just based on the atmospheric temperature and the conditions that are surrounding those cars.
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And so thank you for that, Mr.
Wagner.
And also my question, I have a question about with these rail cars sitting where they do.
and I understand the need for staging and being in a given particular place at any particular time.
What about security for these rail cars?
How do you protect them from being tampered with or potential terrorist activity, that kind of thing?
So rail car security and the security of infrastructure is largely managed through the Department of Transportation through specific regulations and guidelines associated with protection of inventory and commodities in transportation.
And anybody that transports a hazardous material is required to have a DOT security plan and program in place that includes in-transit security.
Part of this is through monitoring of railcars.
It's through effective securement, sealing of railcars, and the application of a specific seal on the railcar to prevent tampering.
Evidence of tampering is easily detectable through that process.
And the FRA is pretty specific with their expectations of continued monitoring of rail cars in transit, as well as the Department of Transportation with all other means of transportation of hazardous materials.
Okay, thank you for that.
Okay, I see Representative Cleaver, last question for this.
We have 20 other people signed up.
I'm sure they can answer your questions.
Thank you very much, and thanks for taking the question, Mr.
Wagner.
I know the times vary tremendously, but on average, during the winter months, what would you say is the average time for storage of rail cars, and what would you say is the average time for storage of rail cars and what would you say is the longest time?
Thank you for that question, Representative Cleaver.
That is a very difficult question to answer specifically because of all the variables.
We have experienced, unfortunately, in the past, substantial delays in delivery of rail cars based on increased demand, as well as unforeseen occurrences, such as the Canadian rail strike or bridges, rail bridges that have been removed from service through flooding and other heavy storms.
So the propane industry attempts to react to that and ensure that those shortfalls are not experienced in the future because they are so detrimental to the citizens of New Hampshire, as well as all across the United States.
So in attempting to forecast what demand is going to be, measure weather patterns, we can expect to have rail cars that are in transit and may be temporarily stored within a location at all different degrees of variation.
It's very difficult to be able to put a specific that this is reasonable or that is reasonable, just based on the fact that it really does come down to what the weather patterns are, what the potential restrictions are, and what other commodities are being shipped on the rail at any given moment.
But I think our rail partners would probably be better able to provide you with more specific information of what they see as their potential storage needs in temporary storage while awaiting delivery to a propane distribution point.
All right.
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony sir uh and actually next up might be somebody who can answer just those types of questions uh cynthia scarano looks like uh from pan am railways uh opposed to the bill uh requesting five minutes, but I'm going to give you three.
Welcome Cynthia Scarano.
I am here.
Good morning.
I think three will be fine.
I think the propane industry did a lot of discussing of issues that we have combined with them.
But if you give me a few moments, I'd like to give you some testimony.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
So, Chairman and members of the Transportation Committee, my name is Cynthia Scurano, and I am the Executive Vice President of Pan Am Railways.
I would like to thank you for the opportunity to testify against House Bill 329, regulating the storage of rail cars containing hazardous materials.
The bill is concerning to Pan Am and the rail industry for many reasons, but the two I would like to focus on today are safety and sufficient energy supply in New Hampshire.
I have worked in my position for 12 years.
During the 12 years, I have had numerous discussions and meetings with New Hampshire officials regarding necessary steps needed to be taken to ensure the sufficient propane supplies reach New Hampshire, thereby meeting its heating and energy needs.
Working closely with our propane customers, we have been able to develop a system that utilizes storage and rail cars so that sufficient supplies are on hand during high demand times such as cold snaps and severe storms.
In this bill, if If this bill were to pass and be found enforceable, there is no question that the supply chain for the propane into New Hampshire would be stressed.
On average, a propane car is loaded at a facility in Ohio, Michigan, wherever in the United States, and it takes from three weeks later to arrive on the Pan Am Railways Network, under the best of circumstances.
If there was some sort of interruption, adverse weather, track issue, cruise shortage, mechanical failure, strikes, bridges, then delivery could take four weeks or more.
The way we have avoided these interruptions affecting household consumers is to have enough cars on our system to feed the storage facilities and keep up with demand while more propane is making its way across country.
Last year, Pan Am Railway shipped over 7,450 car loads of propane.
If we are no longer allowed to place cars along our system for longer than 72 hours, awaiting the need for delivery into facilities, rail transit will no longer be able to keep up with this demand.
Which brings me to the second major concern regarding this bill.
Whether it's chlorine used in water treatment plants or propane used to heat homes, schools, hospitals, and other facilities, rail is the safest form of transportation.
I have included a white paper published by the Association of American Railroads with my testimony that you can read at your leisure.
Some of the points I would like to highlight, though, is the fact that more than 99.9% of rail hazmat shipments reach their destination without a release.
Railroads, including ourselves, have FRA inspectors examine rail infrastructures regularly to ensure compliance with federal standards.
Pan Am conducts weekly inspections of every piece of track and yearly inspection utilizing ultrasonic technology.
Our employees participate in regular training.
PANAM has a rigorous drug and alcohol program.
Employees are subject to random testing, which all employees understand.
PANAM has a zero tolerance for drug and alcohol use.
Our safety department performs training classes and participates in yearly drills with first responders on preparation in the rare event of a rail accident.
Safety is our number one priority.
House Bill 329 will reduce safety by requiring constant movement of hazardous materials in rail cars.
The House Bill also brings about inconsistencies in regulations causing confusion and possible incidents for our employees, the community and our company.
For example, the representative had spoke about placarding.
Railroads do not do the placarding.
The shippers placard what's in their cars.
And a propane tank car, for example, is considered loaded until it is properly flushed and clean.
So even if it's what you and I in the outside world would consider empty, that placard will still say that it has material in it because the placards are for your first responders.
So you want to make sure that they are aware that those cars have or do not have product within them.
Forcing the shuffling of cars every 72 hours takes a safely stored car out of our system and put for no other reason to move it around so that it is not in violation it is our opinion that house bill 329 creates a risk in the shipment of hazardous materials that would otherwise not be there we respectfully request that you deny house bill 329 and i'm happy to answer any questions thank you miss grano seeing Guarano.
Seeing no questions from the committee, thank you very much.
I gave you a little bit more than three, but thank you again.
Thank you, Representative.
We do have to get back on track, hopefully.
I'm not trying to cut anybody short, but we're getting it to the point now.
Everybody's opposed, so I assume we're going to start hearing the same information uh next up patrick hurley from the new hampshire department of transportation who is opposed um also asked for three minutes the sponsor of the bill is trying to get back on mine he's kicked off.
I can't get it either.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Can you hear me now?
Good morning.
We can hear you now.
Thank you.
For the record, my name is Patrick Herlihy.
I'm the director of Aeronautics, Rail and Transit at the New Hampshire Department of Transportation.
As you mentioned, we come today to oppose House Bill 329 as introduced, which would regulate the storage of rail cars containing hazardous materials.
New Hampshire DOT owns approximately 195 miles of active railroad corridors that are currently operated by four freight rail operators and two tourist excursion rail operators.
One of those freight rail operators that was mentioned previously is the New Hampshire Central Railroad, which stores rail cars, which are considered stored in transit, that are either empty or full with hazardous materials.
Our opposition is twofold to this bill.
In most instances, the regulation of railroads and property use for railroad purposes is governed exclusively by the federal government through the U.S.
Surface Transportation Board.
As railroad operations are considered interstate commerce, any such state laws may therefore be federally preempted.
The purpose of federal preemption is to prevent a patchwork of local regulations from unreasonably interfering with interstate commerce.
So for example, the rail cars that are stored by the New Hampshire Central Railroad, which are considered stored in transit, would be considered railroad operations and therefore could be preempted by federal regulations as part of being normal railroad operations.
Secondly, New Hampshire DOT is concerned with the enforcement responsibilities that may become incumbent upon the Bureau of Rail and Transit.
Understanding that this would be an amendment to RSA 21P, it would seem that that enforcement would fall on state police, highway patrol, or other enforcement entities.
State police really have not been enforcing or patrolling railroad corridors here in the state of New Hampshire.
That's been under the purview of the Bureau of Rail and Transit.
So if it's incumbent upon the Bureau to do some kind of enforcement for this bill, we currently have minimal railroad staffing and would require additional staff in order to patrol over 400 miles of privately owned and state-owned active railroads or active railroad corridors.
We certainly, New Hampshire DOT certainly appreciates concerns regarding the storage of hazardous materials, but as you've heard from others today, the regulatory and safety aspect that's already been given or used by the federal government and also by local authorities has made this as safe as it possibly can be.
And with that, I can take some questions.
I'll be happy to take some questions.
Thank you.
Thank you, testimony.
I see one question.
Representative Gorski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Mr.
Hurley, for taking my question.
You mentioned that you have minimal staffing right now and would require more staffing if this bill was passed.
Can you give us a ballpark of what's minimal staffing mean now and what would you need for additional staffing if this passed?
What I need for additional staffing, I'm really not quite sure because we would have to see what this, how we would patrol those 440 miles.
Minimal staffing to me means I have a, in my railroad unit, I have a railroad planner.
I have an operations engineer who inspects projects that are done along the state-owned railroad lines.
And I have a railroad inspector and investigator.
And that inspector is responsible for going out to make sure that the railroad lines themselves are in adequate shape and that the inspections have been done by the railroads to operate on our state railroad lines.
And that person also goes out for any accidents or incidents that happen along the railroad lines.
Okay thank you.
Thank you.
Seeing no other questions thank you Mr.
Hurley.
Thank you very much Mr.
Chairman and members of the Transportation Committee.
Okay next up I'm going to go with Edward Jeffrey, New Hampshire, representing New Hampshire Central Railroad Incorporated, opposed to the bill.
And he's requested zero minutes.
So I'm going to be fair and I'm going to give you two.
Are you there, Mr.
Jeffrey?
Is he still muted?
No, he's unmuted.
Mr.
Edward, can you hear us?
Maybe he really did want zero minutes.
It's Edward Jeffrey.
Yep.
Mr.
Jeffrey.
Going once.
Going twice.
Mr.
Jeffrey, if you are having issues, you can try again at the end.
But we need to move along.
So next up, I'm going to go with Mr.
Robert Scully, representing the New Hampshire Motor Transport Association, also opposed to the bill, and is asking for three minutes say you there mr scully mr chairman can you help me can hear you now good morning good morning thank you mr chairman members of the committee i'll be brief.
I know you're busy.
I will not repeat myself.
I'm the president of New Hampshire Motor Transport Association.
I appear in opposition to House Bill 325 for many of the comments that have already been raised.
I also appear on behalf of the Energy Marketers Association of New Hampshire, and that is all our propane dealers in the state of New Hampshire.
And I just use this winter weather that we're having as an example of if we had supply interruption, what it would mean to your constituents in your homes, to homeowners, small businesses, hospitals, schools.
You cannot predict what is going to happen with the weather and what a great need or demand that might be increased.
And this fuel that we're talking about, very specifically propane, is in those rail cars so that this industry and the state can meet the needs of the customers and its people to keep folks warm and safe and comfortable in the winter.
And I'll just bring you back to three or four years ago when we had a deep freeze for over three weeks.
This, my office was working with the governor and his folks fielding phone calls from around the state of New Hampshire, because we couldn't get, it was a great need or demand for people to get fuel to keep themselves warm.
So we met that need.
But if we did not have the ability to get the product where it was staged, to get the customers, there were folks that would have went without heat.
So I'll leave the rest of it to you for anyone else from the industry that can ask specific questions.
But I view this bill as extremely harmful to the end users of the product that really take sometimes for granted that their houses and business and schools and hospitals are going to get the product they need to keep warm.
So thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, sir.
Seeing no questions, I'll thank you again.
And next up, Thomas Manson, a member of the public opposed to the bill, like to testify as requested three minutes.
Are you there, Mr.
Manson?
Leads on mute.
Can you hear me, Mr.
Chairman?
You can now, good morning, sir.
Good morning, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
Thank you very much.
My name is Tom Manson.
I'm the CEO of Eastern Propane and Oil, and I'm here to testify in opposition to House Bill 329.
Also scheduled to testify this morning, Mr.
Chairman, on behalf of Eastern is Bob LaFave, our Vice President of Supply.
In the interest of time and with your permission, included in my testimony, I would read his brief statement regarding the specifics of the effect of House Bill 329 on our rail terminal, if that would be acceptable to the committee.
He is available to answer any specific questions you may have about how we operate our rail terminal.
Yeah, what was his name again?
His name is Bob Lefebvre, L-E-F-E-V-V-R-E.
I've got him there.
I think that would be fine.
It helps to save some time.
If there are any questions for him, we can reach out to him.
So thank you.
Wonderful.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
As I said, I am the CEO of Eastern Propane and Oil, headquartered in Rochester, New Hampshire.
I'm also a citizen of New Hampshire, living in Newcastle.
Eastern Propane and Oil is a fourth generation family business with our headquarters in Rochester, New Hampshire.
We serve 56,000 customers in New Hampshire meeting their fuel needs, primarily propane and heating oil.
We have 380 employees in New Hampshire.
We have offices in Rochester, Wolfboro, Tamworth, North Conway, Hudson, Loudon, Enfield, and Claremont.
We have 16 storage facilities for fuel in New Hampshire, including a 900,000-gallon propane storage facility, a rail terminal in North Rochester, New Hampshire.
Our concern is that House Bill 329 would adversely affect the operation of the facility and our ability to efficiently and effectively provide fuel to our customers in New Hampshire.
And now I'll turn, if I might, to the testimony of Bob LaFave, who is responsible for managing all of our supply facilities, including our rail terminal in North Rochester, New Hampshire.
And he was his statement.
Good morning, my name is Bob Lefebvre and I'm here this morning to voice my opposition to House Bill 329.
One of my responsibilities as Vice President of Supply for Eastern Propane is to maintain adequate inventory levels at our 900,000 gallon rail facility for propane storage located in Rochester, New Hampshire.
This terminal processes upwards of 24 million gallons of propane annually, equating to roughly 800 rail cars, with each car containing approximately 30,000 gallons of propane.
The terminal and the rail cars we bring in play a key role in allowing us to serve our customers with propane as demand warrants.
We use this facility to load our delivery trucks, which in turn fuel the customers' tanks.
Our propane is used to service hospitals, schools, government buildings, manufacturers, businesses, restaurants, and homes.
The customers use the propane for emergency generators, heating, cooking, hot water, clothes drying, auto gas, and other uses.
Propane rail cars are not an on-demand commodity, meaning we can't pick up the phone or send an email and have the cars at our terminal tomorrow.
From the time you order a rail car to the time it arrives, it can take up words of 15 days depending on where it is in the country it was shipped from.
It takes planning to ensure we have adequate product on hand to meet the demand of the customers, especially in peak season.
At times, the railroad can have and has had issues being able to move rail cars for a variety of reasons, and it's in those times we rely on the cars we have on hand.
By having the ability to store cars at the terminal, it guarantees we'll have the product to help avoid disruption or at least to help bridge the gap until rail service is restored.
There is not an endless supply of rail cars in the supply chain.
We are always unloading the cars as quickly as possible, which allows us to get them back to the supplier to be reloaded for the return trip.
Should this bill be enacted, the provisions contained would greatly impact supply security by limiting the number of cars we have on hand at any given time.
I'll end on this note.
For every rail car that enters the state of New Hampshire, it keeps three 18-wheel transports off New Hampshire highways.
In our case, Eastern keeps roughly 2,400 transports off New Hampshire highways each year.
Should we be limited to the amount of rail cars we can bring to our terminal, we would have no other choice but to start hauling more of the product by means of transports.
I thank you for allowing me to speak in opposition to House Bill 329.
Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee, thank you for your time.
And that concludes my testimony and Mr.
LeFave's testimony on behalf of Eastern Propane and Oil.
Thank you very much, sir.
Seeing no...
Can you send that testimony?
Oh, did you...
Have you provided the committee with written testimony?
We have not.
I just received this this morning, but we can certainly do so after the fact.
If you could forward it, that would be great.
Thank you, sir.
You're quite welcome.
I'm seeing no questions, so thank you again.
Have a great day.
Yeah, you as well.
Move on to Leslie Anderson, a member of the public representing herself.
She is opposed.
Perhaps this could be a mistake.
Also asking for zero minutes.
Could have signed up wrong, but if you're there, Leslie Anderson.
I can see you, but you're still on mute.
Can you hear me now, Mr.
Chairman?
I can, good morning.
Good morning, thank you.
Good morning, Chairman Walsh and members of the committee.
My name is Leslie Anderson, and I'm president of the Propane Gas Association of New England, and I thank you all for the opportunity to offer our comments in opposition of House Bill 329.
The Propane Gas Association is a regional alternative energy trade association.
We represent members of the propane industry, including the two you've heard from today, as well as many small family-owned businesses here in New Hampshire.
Over 40 propane marketers in your state and more than 2,700 employees.
We exist to serve the industry by promoting safety, education, and public awareness.
Propane is a recognized clean alternative fuel by EPA under the 1990 Clean Air Act, and it's essential as a backup for our ever-increasing use of the electrical grid.
Using clean propane energy accelerates decarbonization and access to clean propane ensures environmental equity.
We oppose House Bill 329 as it would threaten the health and safety of New Hampshire's citizens.
We rely on propane rail cars in New Hampshire to supply over 230,000 residential customers as well as critical public services and businesses.
Rail transportation is the most economical, the cleanest, and the safest method to supply propane to our infrastructure throughout the state.
As you've heard, there will be train delays due to storms in the winter due to heavy snow, natural disasters like floods that wash out rail bridges or collapse tunnels.
Rail strikes in Canada have caused disruptions in the last years.
And for these reasons, the railroads and our rail customers have built in additional supply to ensure that they have a working inventory readily available.
Our average working inventory is seven to 10 days of supply.
And by doing this, we make sure that the propane industry not only provides warm heating and hot water to New Hampshire's businesses year round into the homes, but also to protect the state's energy security and its resiliency needs.
Using rail cars reduces the number of trucks on our state highways, as one rail car is equal to three large 18-wheeler transport trailer trucks.
Rail reduces the burden of vehicles on the state roads and highways, and it lowers the risk of vehicle incidents.
We estimate that this bill would add millions of dollars in infrastructure costs to our members in the form of additional tractor-trailer trucks, which they would have to buy if they could not use the rails that they use currently for inventory.
And these trucks run $350,000 to $400,000 a piece.
We also estimate that this bill would add an additional 15 cents per gallon to consumers for the cost of product due to increased transportation costs if we couldn't use the efficiency of rail.
Propane is not only an EPA certified alternative fuel but we're also a federally certified emergency civil defense energy.
When winter storms, natural disasters or pandemics call for portable energy or backup energy generators or cell phone tower energy so that we can communicate throughout the state, propane is the one that steps in and saves the day.
Whether it's a small outdoor restaurant heating with outdoor space with propane barbecue tank or a large hospital or school using propane to heat and as backup power generation.
Residents need it to boil water and cook food when their power is out.
So propane is there to supply clean, reliable energy and is an important part of New Hampshire's plan.
We do suspect that there are several aspects of this bill that would be preempted by federal regulations.
I'll let the others on the call speak to that issue.
But in conclusion, I'd just like to say that to ensure the safety of our citizens when there are electrical disruptions and storms, climate disasters, and even cyber terrorism, it's really essential that the state promote the energy infrastructure and transportation of sustainable green resilient energies like propane.
So for these reasons, we respectfully request the committee to vote no on House Bill 329, and I would be happy to answer any of your questions.
Thank you very much.
I see no questions, so thank you again.
Do you have any written testimony you can provide the committee?
I do.
I've emailed it to the committee.
Oh, you did?
Okay.
Thank you very much again.
That's the last person I've signed to speak up.
I'll go back one more time to Edward Jeffrey, if he's still there, in all fairness.
Well, that's three attempts, so I'll make note of that.
On the rest of our sheet, signed up by also in opposition, is one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Seven more members of the public, six more opposed.
Representative Leishman is also opposed.
And we have a neutral, Mr.
Eric Rathburg.
I'll see you next time.
more um opposed representative leishman is also opposed and we have a neutral uh mr eric rathburg um so with that i'm going to close the public hearing on house bill 329 give us a few minutes to reset and mr greenland if you can send me a refresh link i'm hearing a couple of people who have problems getting bounced out they won't let me it It says the webinar has expired.
So if it should be another one, that'd be great.
All right, I will send that over to you right now.
Thank you.
So now to reset.
What?
Between here.
Yeah, we're a half hour.
I thought I was up at 10.30.
Yeah.
You're early.
Yeah, you're early.
Because we're early.
Thank you.
Sound check.
Can everybody hear me?
Can I hear you well?
Okay.
Is Howard Pearl on the line?
Representative O'Hara?
My computer's not working.
There he is.
Good morning.
All right.
Can you hear me?
Good morning.
Chairman, can you hear me okay?
I can now.
Good morning.
All right.
Chairman Walsh and members of the Transportation Committee.
I am here this morning to introduce House Bill 279.
For the record, my name is Howard Pearl.
I'm representative from Merrimack 26, covering the towns of Loudoun, Bosquin, Northfield, Canterbury, and Ward 3 of Franklin.
First off, I want to wish a happy birthday to Vice Chair Gagney.
I can't believe he's 77.
all right so good morning i'm here to as i said to to introduce house bill 279 a bill that would allow a higher tandem axle weight for tractor trailers hauling forest products i emailed out an amendment yesterday to the whole committee i I hope you received it.
Amendment 2021-0319H.
Department of Safety requested that I make slight language change to better clarify the goals of the bill.
So if you've got that, it generally is the same as the original bill, except it's a little bit more clarifying language.
So I worked with the Commissioner of Safety, Commissioner Quinn, Sergeant Burke, and the New Hampshire Motor Transport Association and the Timberland Owners Association to craft the language that you have in this bill.
There's been some issues with, especially with the folks hauling wood chips over the roads, they've been running into some problems and complying with the current language.
So as you can see, the language is very specific about what vehicles it would allow the exception to or the weight change exception.
And the part that the amendment adds is for purposes of this subparagraph, raw forestry products means unprocessed logs and wood chips harvested from forest land as defined, excuse me, in RSA 227 G2 section 8 that have not previously been moved off site.
And the reason we added that language and that safety requested it is we wanted to make sure that this only applied to loads that were coming off the log landing and not loads that had gone to say a reloading site because those loads can be metered and loaded properly in order to make sure that they're complying with the axle weight restrictions.
The situation occurs mostly, almost completely with loads that are coming off from the log landing, and especially with these loads of chips that have been blown into a tractor trailer, and they're not able to properly get that load in the right places in order to comply with the current statute.
So this language, the way it's presented with the weight rating at 40,000, would put us in line with the state of Maine.
Maine is currently at 44,000, but with our statute, we have a 5% overage allowance.
So by putting it at 40,000 with the 5% overage allowance, Allowance Department of Safety felt this would get us to 44,000 and they'd safely be able to still manage that.
And the Timbaland owners felt that the 44,000 weight would solve virtually all of the issues that their members have been having.
I looked at Vermont as well.
Vermont is even higher.
It's at nearly 50,000.
I felt that and Department of Safety felt that that wasn't necessary.
So we stopped at the current language of 40,000.
The low-grade forestry industry in New Hampshire is struggling already.
This bill will leave an unnecessary hurdle for them to get their product to market.
I know you will receive some testimony from Department of Transportation that they had some concerns.
So in regards to their concerns about the damage to our roads and bridges, it is my belief that New Hampshire roads and bridges are built to the same standards as our neighboring states to the east and the west.
The trailers of wood chips that are loaded on site are not easy to divide to meet the current axle weight restrictions.
The forest industry has tried many different techniques to achieve compliance to no avail.
I know you're running late, so in closing, I'll reiterate that I'm not looking to increase the overall weight of the vehicles, just the distribution of weight for this very narrow use that has demonstrated the need for relief.
With that, I will take any questions from the committee, and I'll just say that there's a couple other folks that are coming up to testify as well that if you have some technical questions, they may be their industry representatives and they may be better qualified to answer than I am.
Thank you.
Appreciate the time.
Jason Stott, the Hitcher Timbaland Ores Association in support is seeking formance.
Give us a start.
The support is seeking four minutes.
Okay.
Can you hear me?
You can.
Good morning, sir.
Okay.
Good morning.
The system's a little glitchy.
When you called my name, I got bumped off the meeting and then reintroduced.
So I was not asleep at the switch, I guess.
So for the record, this is Jason Stock.
I'm with the New Hampshire Timberland Owners Association.
And I want to thank Representative Pearl for introducing this bill.
And I also want to thank the folks at the Department of Safety for helping us work on it.
As Representative Pearl indicated in the forest products industry, hitting axle weights can be very difficult.
Most trucks that are hauling across the road, these are the tractor trailer style truck, they're certified to 99,000 pounds and whether you're blowing chips into the truck or you're putting logs on it you know attaining that gross vehicle weight you can you can usually get pretty close particularly with the 10 overage but where it gets difficult is when you're trying to hit those particular, those specific axle weights, especially over the drive axles.
And so this bill will go, will help resolve that, help resolve that issue.
The current axle weight limit for a tandem axle is 36,000 pounds.
As Representative Pearl said, it's 40,000 in Maine and of course, or 44,000 in Maine and in Vermont, it's as high as 50.
I've heard for many, a number of years that, you know, truckers say it just doesn't make sense.
I load a truck up let's say I load a truck up in Vermont I'm legal I that truckers say it just doesn't make sense.
I load a truck up.
Let's say I load a truck up in Vermont.
I'm legal.
I cross the Connecticut River.
I'm illegal.
And then I cross into Maine and I'm legal again.
I said, this just doesn't make sense.
And it's really, it's not a gross vehicle weight.
It's a, it's that axle weight.
And what makes it tricky is when you're on a log landing, it is not like a dooryard or a, you know, the yard of a trucking facility that's paved and level.
You're on a surface that is usually there's some slope to it.
it's a it's a soil so you's soil.
And so, you know, trying to hit those axle numbers and haul a legal load at 99,000 pounds gross vehicle weight, again, it's near impossible to hit those axle weights.
Our feeling is let's get consistent with with main um this and it will make it just seems to make sense and i know i have i think i have one trucker on the line today that can speak to this he hauls in all three states um and he can kind of give a little bit of the history about when you know know, the original axle weights were set up, you know, we were looking at a bridge formula of 80,000, we now can go certified 99,000, and that's great, but the axles didn't, the axle weights, what he's telling me is they didn't change, so despite the additional 99,000 pound payload, 99,000, yeah, we still have this axle.
So again, I appreciate the help from Representative Pearl and the Department of Safety in putting this together.
And I'd be happy to try and answer any questions.
And hopefully my guy who's on the road, he assured me he would be pulled over for the hearing and call in.
Hopefully he's able to make it and he can answer more specific on the ground questions.
But again, I appreciate the opportunity to testify.
I hope you'll support this bill.
And again, I'll try to answer any questions.
Thank you, sir.
Seeing no questions, thanks again.
Next up, we will go with Errol Peters, a member of the public, representing himself in support of the bill, only asking for two minutes.
I'm going to have to start holding people to this.
Are you there, Mr.
Peters?
I am not seeing him.
If you can raise his hand, that might help.
He's not online?
I don't see him.
Fair enough.
Okay.
Next, we'll go with Robert Scully from the New Hampshire Motor Transport Association.
In support.
Asking for three minutes.
Oh, there he is.
I got one second.
There we go.
Mr.
Chairman, can you hear me?
Good morning again.
Good morning.
Just for note, the previous hearing I testified on, I was removed from the Zoom meeting, and I had a very difficult time getting back on here just for future reference.
So, you know, so I missed the previous speakers on this bill.
I'll try to be very brief.
I appear in support of this piece of legislation.
And just to put it in perspective of what we're asking for and support is an extremely small segment of the trucking industry.
We're only talking about forest products coming off the land to have an equity in the axle weight system.
Currently today, these trucking companies that perform this service can legally have a load of 99,000 pounds and, however, have their axle weight be over the 36,000 pounds and it usually happens on the drive axles so we met with the department of safety with representative pearl who introduced the legislation we did our best to come up with a recommendation that worked for the industry and was still safe on the highways.
And our best opportunity to do that was to mirror what they have in the state of Maine to try to fix what we view as an inequity for a, once again, a very small segment of the industry.
There are no other portions of the trucking world that I represent that is asking for this.
It is just the forest products that come off the land.
We're trying to fix a problem Thank you.
portions of the trucking world that I represent that is asking for this.
It is just the forest products that come off the land.
We're trying to fix a problem where they can legally be at maximum weight, but still be receiving a citation for maximum axle weights.
And if in fact, we mirror what we have in the state of Maine and you distribute the axle weights appropriately on the tires and on the truck itself, then as far as I'm concerned in reading the letter from the Department of Transportation, we are properly riding with a legal load and spreading out any potential damage to the road.
So we don't agree with their assessment, and we would ask the committee to kindly consider support of this legislation.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Mrs.
Kelly.
Any questions from the committee?
Representative O'Hara?
I would just like to apologize to Mrs.
Kelly.
I was clicking the wrong button when I was taking people off of panelists.
Thank you.
I just didn't want to miss it.
All right.
Seeing all the questions, thank you again, sir.
Yeah.
Last up, we're going to go with Mr.
Rodriguez from the Department of Transportation.
They are opposed.
I see he's done it for five.
If you could speed that up, good morning, sir.
Thank you very much for making time to hear my testimony today.
I do have prepared testimony, but before I start, I want to make an illustration of what we would call the difference between a distributed load and the point load.
When we talk about a fully loaded vehicle and we distribute the load among many axles, we equal out those point loads so no point load is too high.
When we're talking about axle loads, we're talking about direct point loads in a single location that has a significantly different effect on a road or bridge.
So to use a forest analogy, if you're splitting wood, you have a piece of wood, you hit it with the blunt end of a sledgehammer, you probably won't split it.
But if you hit it with the sharp end of the mall or the axe, you're going to split that Thank you.
hammer, you probably won't split it.
But if you hit it with the sharp end of the mall or the axe, you're going to split that wood because you're concentrating all of that force in one location.
And that's what axle weights do.
They're concentrating forces at one location.
And And that's why higher axle loads impact our bridges and roads differently than an overall vehicle load that distributes that load over many axles.
So the department's testimony is HB 279 proposes a change in RSA 266-B, weight on non-interstate and general highway system for vehicles with additional registrations.
So this is a subset of our vehicles that we allow to run heavier than our regular vehicles already due to this certification.
HB 279 would provide a carve-out for forest products, allowing a combination of truck tractor and single semi-trailer with four or more axles that is carrying forest products to increase the weight on any tandem axle from 36,000 to 40,000 pounds.
This equates to an increase of 11%.
And as was mentioned, that can be, there's a tolerance of 10%, which means that axle load can now be up to 44,000 pounds.
The Department of Transportation opposes this bill.
Passage of this House bill will impact the posting of bridges in New Hampshire, a road safety factors, and increase the deterioration of existing bridges and roadway pavements.
We also have concern that this could lead to demand for similar treatment from other industries.
These are divisible loads, meaning a divisible load is a load that you meter by how much you put on a particular vehicle.
You can put more or less.
These are divisible loads and should be held to consistent limits currently set forth in statute.
New Hampshire laws restrict the weight of vehicles for two major reasons.
The first reason the laws limit the weight of vehicles is that vehicles are designed and built to safely carry a finite weight.
Distribution of that weight affects different safety things such as steering, braking, stability, and other safety characteristics, as well as the overall ability of the vehicle to carry the loads.
Department of Safety is expert in those factors.
The second reason the laws limit weight is that our roads and bridges are engineered to support specific loads from the vehicles, and the Department of Transportation is expert on these factors.
New Hampshire's roadway network is comprised of a series of roads, including state and local highways and back roads.
Our interstates are relatively modern, with highly engineered roadways and bridges.
They are also more highly regulated when it comes to weight to protect the federal taxpayers' significant investment and to preserve the nation's ability to move commerce and defense assets across the country uninterrupted.
RSA Section 266.18B exercises New Hampshire's choice to increase the allowable weight of vehicles on New Hampshire's non-interstate system that is not as tightly regulated from a federal level.
So what we're saying, we let heavier vehicles drive on our less engineered and less built local roads as opposed to the interstates.
Unfortunately, while some of the non-interstate system is made up of highly engineered roadways and bridges, much of this system is made up of roadways that have never been formally engineered or constructed.
Many of the state and local bridges on the non-interstate system are old and were built to carry much lighter vehicles and travel on them today.
The load increase proposed in HB 279 will have the greatest effect on our shorter, older bridges, which were designed for lower loading standards, and on the pavement on our state and local roads that were never formally constructed.
Fortunately, New Hampshire DOT has a sophisticated bridge inspection program and the ability to rate all our state and local bridges for specific loads.
The department post Thank you.
bridge inspection program and the ability to rate all our state and local bridges for specific loads.
The department posts state bridges and directs towns to post their bridges that cannot support specific loads.
Passage of HB 279 would require the department to spend approximately 7,700 hours to reanalyze and rate all the state's bridges for these proposed higher axle weights.
And as a result, this will almost certainly lead to the posting of additional bridges, increasing the number of E2 postings.
The following graphic explains the E2 posting.
The E2 posting prohibits all certified vehicles from crossing the posted bridge.
Passage of this bill will prohibit all certified vehicles from these additional posted bridges, not just trucks carrying forest products.
So if this bill passes, we will have to reanalyze all of our bridges, and we will have to post bridges to prohibit all trucks in this classification from passing additional structures, meaning it doesn't matter if you're a forest truck, a gravel truck, a milk truck, you won't be able to cross that bridge.
In addition to posting...
Mr.
Rodriguez.
Yes.
Yeah, I don't mean to interrupt, sir.
I finally recognize the fact that you're actually just rereading your written testimony.
We've all read it, I believe, already.
Do you have anything to add that you can summarize?
Because when you actually get into the graphs and pictures in it, obviously we don't have that in front of us.
So could you maybe summarize, and we can, like I say, reread the testimony ourselves?
Yes, absolutely, Mr.
Chairman.
And again, passage of this bill will require all trucks to take different routes in some cases where we have additional posted bridges.
Finally, even though it's a small 10% increase in the weight of the axle, that has a one and a half times greater impact on our pavements.
Again, in the weight of the axle that has a one and a half times greater impact on our pavements, again, particularly for our back roads that were never formally constructed.
And I'll take any questions, Mr.
Chairman.
I see one question from Senator Barrett.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for your testimony, Mr.
Rodriguez.
So the previous person who testified said that they have a truck will come from Vermont, which is legal there, cross into New Hampshire, which would be illegal, and then go to Maine, which would be legal.
So that leads me, a question as to why would Vermont and Maine consider those vehicles safe for their roads?
I mean, are our roads in New Hampshire built to less of a standard than, say in Vermont and Maine?
So, I, I, roads in New Hampshire built to less of a standard than, say, in Vermont and Maine?
So the roadways are very similar standards, and their roads will see higher deterioration based on those heavier loads.
That's a fact.
And in driving on some of those roads, we can see that.
The difference with bridges is, unfortunately, every state's loads are unique to a large extent, except on the federal highway system.
So when it comes to bridges and rating our bridges, each of us rate our bridges to our axle weight and vehicle weight laws.
So Vermont and Maine, as they analyze their bridges, they would consider these heavy loads and post vehicles from those bridges that they can't drive over.
We would need to redo that for New Hampshire bridges for these heavier loads.
Thank you.
Representative Borski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Mr.
Rodriguez, for answering my question.
You mentioned that there's a lot of roads and bridges that could have some negative impacts if this bill was passed.
I'm not sure if you know this answer, but can you give us what percentage of roads or bridges could be impacted if this was passed?
So the percentage of roads, all of our back roads that experience higher roads like this would be impacted by it.
When it comes to bridges, we're talking, we have to crunch your math, so this is gross estimation, we're talking about dozens, not hundreds.
Okay, thank you.
Senator Skes?
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Mr.
Rodriguez, in planning, the DOT has an estimate of what percentage of roads it's able to upkeep and repair over a given year and that number as I recall has been going percentage that they're able to do has been going down and down.
Will there be that kind of an effect if this bill passes making fewer roads being repaired on time?
So passage of this bill would not affect the rate at which we reconstruct roads and maintenance of the roads, pavements of the roads and so forth.
Passage of this bill would have a small effect on the condition of those pavements and the rates at which they deteriorate.
May I have a follow-up, Mr.
Chairman?
Follow-up, go ahead.
Yeah, but what you're saying is that the roads will be less, they'll take further, I don't know if this is the right word, but more wear and tear, and won't that push, put more pressure on the DOT to get roads repaired faster?
It absolutely will.
We already feel that pressure to repair and reconstruct roads quicker.
We feel that pressure all the time.
Some of you who drive on many of our back roads likely feel that pressure too.
Thank you.
Okay.
Seeing no other questions, thank you very much, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I believe that is our last person signed up to speak.
Is there anybody in the queue?
Is there anybody in the queue, Representative O'Hara?
There is one.
Hold on.
New Hampshire State Police, Bill Burke.
Okay.
If you can queue them up, what was his name?
Bill Burke.
Okay.
What was his name?
Bill Burke.
Okay.
Need to unmute.
Mr.
Burke.
Can you hear me sir??
Good morning.
Thank you.
It booted me off there for a second.
I apologize, Mr.
Chairman.
No problem.
It's all yours.
My name is Bill Burke.
I'm the assistant troop commander of Troop G.
We were asked to join a meeting with the New Hampshire Timbaland Association and the commissioner's office on this.
and the main question that was asked to the state police was, are the trucks capable of carrying this amount of weight and in our estimation the majority of trucks out there that do carry this type of product can carry this type of weight safely.
That was the question that was asked to us.
We agree with the Timbaland Association that it is an issue with the forestry, especially with wood chips.
They have a hard time regulating wood chips going into these trucks.
It's tough to do, and we do catch axle violations on them quite frequently.
We're just trying to give them a little bit of reprieve on this type of issue.
I'm available for questions if you have anything from us.
Senator Barron, thank you, sir.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Mr.
Burke, for your testimony.
I'm interested to know that, you know, the vehicles that we're talking about now, they're certified overweight vehicles currently.
So what bridges are they allowed to use now, but would be eliminated from service because of the limited use of this exception?
Well, Representative Aaron, DOT posts the bridges.
We don't post the bridges.
We would have to catch them going over the bridge in order to hit them with a bridge violation, which we rarely have the opportunity to do that, catch them going over the E2 bridge.
Have we caught them in the past?
Yes, but it's not something that we grab a lot of the time.
If I'm answering your question correctly.
Thank you.
in the past, yes, but it's not something that we grab a lot of the time.
I'm answering your question correctly.
Thank you.
Okay.
Seeing no other questions.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
And I don't see any other hands up.
Any other hands up?
Representative O'Hara?
No, I don't see any.
Okay.
For the record.
Let's see.
No, I don't see any.
Okay.
For the record, we have in support and a member of the public, Eric Rathburn, our friend who is neutral on We have in support and a member of the public, Eric Rathburn, our friend who is neutral on this bill.
With that, I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 279.
Just a few minutes to reset.
Thank you.
Yeah, we're having glitches with the big screen here.
Did they all hear the testimony?
Did you hear the testimony at all from Representative Smith?
No.
You didn't hear it?
Okay.
I didn't know you even started.
We're taking a break.
That was a practice.
If you would repeat yourself.
I'll try, you know, I make this stuff up as I go along.
So, but yeah, I'll take another swing at it.
So, yeah, and the chair did open the public hearing and I am Representative Stephen Smith, Sullivan County District 11, Eckworth, Charlestown, Goshen Langdon, Lemster, and Washington.
In 2013, I brought forward a bill to try to get a group to work on a regulatory package for personal rapid transit systems.
These are small and lightweight.
If you want to see some examples of good working ones, look up Heathrow Airport PRT or Morgantown, West Virginia, where a similar type of white transportation system has been operating since the 70s.
That didn't go anywhere because I failed to show the legislature working models and viable projects.
Since then I've been contacted by manufacturers who would like to do these things and different modalities.
Many of you have heard of Dean Kamen some years ago.
He pitched a microchain proposal for the city of Manchester, which would not require bulldozing or blasting.
It's a small lightweight system that could have been put in.
He offered to pay for it.
And because of a failure to convey what it would actually look like and how it would be implemented, that never went anywhere.
And I'm trying to fix that.
So the different types of things that we need are for less populated parts of the state where we don't have masses.
So we can't have mass transit, but we still need public transportation.
Personal rapid transit systems differ from conventional transportation in that they don't run around empty.
If nobody calls a car, no car moves.
That's distributed car software.
So the units on the network are staged so that you never have to wait more than 10 or 15 minutes, which is the cycle time of the New York City subway system.
And you press the button, the thing shows up, you swipe your card and off you go.
The only real estate you need for some of them is maybe access to a state highway right-of-way and room to put an 18-inch in diameter pole, and then they hang from a cable or rail, much like the gondolas at our ski resorts.
There's pneumatic tube technology for people.
There's a pilot project out in Las Vegas or somewhere in Nevada.
And that's kind of exciting.
So between the PRT systems, the micro rail, solar powered street car project in the Southwest, there's a lot of different ways to move people around that I don't think get enough interest, exposure, and we devolve into the fighting about subsidizing buses and trains thing so what i'm going to ask the committee to do is retain the bill and i will talk to the manufacturers and mr kamen who have talked to me about this and they will either come here before you and show you a project that convinces you this is worth looking at or not if that doesn't happen then it won't cost you anything because I imagine there will be no work sessions and I'll make the motion to ITL in October myself.
But think of the possibilities of getting not really cool 20th century technology, but actually looking to the 21st for a change.
And I hope you can support that and take the journey with me.
Thank you, Representative Smith.
Could you highlight again that who's paying for this?
Who's paying for?
Who's going to be paying if these projects would get off the ground?
Yes, these are private investors that want to build these things.
And they're taking a long view that whatever the cost to put them in, yes, they're going to need investors up front and also, frankly, some federal money available.
But that long term, once the federal money pays off the initial debt of the build, they're going to be collecting fares.
And the nice thing about these is maintenance on them is minimal on the classic PRT systems.
And also being solar powered, they don't have electricity generating bills or fuel costs.
So it's literally just maintenance.
Keep them clean, keep them greased, and they keep running.
So it's all private money.
So generally speaking, these things would turn a profit and we wouldn't have to subsidize.
That's the hope.
Yeah.
Imagine if they can't profit from it, they have to subsidize.
That's what, that's the hope.
Yeah.
Imagine if they can't profit from it, they won't build it.
Thank you.
Do you have any questions?
Any committee members?
Representative Gorski.
Thank you, Mr.
Vice Chairman.
And thank you, Representative Smith for this bill.
Let me ask, can you repeat those two examples you mentioned?
You mentioned Hawthorne Airport.
And what was the other example that we could take a look at?
Heathrow Airport in England and Morganstown, West Virginia.
And I bring those up because the one in West Virginia has been there since the 70s.
And it's almost more light rail, so a super early version.
Heathrow, that is a dedicated roadway system, so they built like concrete troughs for it, but the distribution software is state-of-the-art.
So those are two good things to kind of get your head around the concept.
You can also look up Transit X, all one word, the word transit with the letter X on the end, a Massachusetts company that has some very good concept drawings.
Thank you.
Representative Talarski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Smith, can you just clarify, I want to make sure I understood you correctly, that you're hoping we retain this so we can work on a little bit more and get feedback from other industries?
Absolutely.
So if they can't come here and pitch, I'm not going to lie, a couple of the companies I looked at I suspect are vaporware, so they have a concept but not an actual implementation package.
In order for them to actually convince us that we should spend our time on it, I want to see a guy come in here and say, I can do this for the UNH campus tomorrow or Dartmouth or Concord to connect the parking garages, you know, and then we can move forward and we can always amend the bill to create the regulatory parameters that will be needed.
If you were around when we did the Uber bill, when you have a new transportation technology, a challenge for a manufacturer is they want to know what the rules are, what regulations will they have to adhere to before they spend money, and frankly, what they can be sued for.
So if they come in and convince you, that could be an appropriate amendment for the bill prior to sending anything to the Senate.
Or as I said, they won't show up, in which case it's an ITL, and we took a swing at it.
Thank you.
Any other questions from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you, Representative Smith.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
seeing as there are no other signed up speakers, is there anyone out there in the queue who would wish to speak on this matter?
Yes, there's one that is John and or Betty Gay.
Okay.
You need to unmute, Representative Gay.
Yes, and I put my hand up because I'm presenting the next bill, and this was the way I thought I was supposed to do it, so I apologize.
Steve's representative Smith's idea sounds fabulous.
Thank you.
Okay.
Seeing no further people in the queue.
There are those who chose not to testify in person here.
There are seven supporters, two opposed to this bill.
And with that, I close House Bill 104.
A little closer.
To oppose.
Yeah, you want to see?
Thank you.
I thought I was going to get up.
Did you guys accept me anything?
I'm booked for the afternoon.
The window was now.
I saw the bill you found.
Thank you.
Okay.
For some reason today, the main terminal keeps going on to mute mode.
Did anybody hear anything I said a few moments ago?
Okay, before we get started, I've got 11 people signed up to speak, all in opposition, anywhere from most of them from zero minutes requested to three.
So I'm going to pick three minutes.
I'm going to ask the vice chair to keep track of time.
I will ask everybody that signed up to speak, if you have provided the committee with written testimony, to please not just read it back to us.
I think most of us spent the night last night reading them all.
That being said, look for the prime sponsor.
And actually, if you didn't hear anything, I guess I need to start over.
when opened the public hearing in House Bill 587 relative to indicating citizenship or legal residency on driver's licenses and non-drivers identification cards.
So Representative Gay.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman.
I will be as brief as possible.
This is an issue that doesn't seem too related to transportation, except that our driver's licenses are issued by the DOT.
And I come from a background of election law, although I like being on health and human services now, too.
one of the difficulties in signing people up, registering people to vote, is that they have to show that they're citizens.
Well, if you can't show it on your driver's license, that means you have to go dig for your birth certificate or some other document that is official.
we use our driver's licenses frequently, mostly not for driving.
I mean, we have to have it for driving, but we mostly use it as our personal ID.
So, it would be so nice to put just in some kind of mark, and I did not specify exactly what kind because I wanted to leave that up to the people who actually do it.
So I found the phrase among other RSAs, an improved security marking indicating.
So it's either indicating citizenship or legal residency.
Those are the only people who can have a driver's license.
If you're illegal, you can't have one or you buy it from some fence.
So this is a very simple reason to have it.
It doesn't have to be big words splashed across, but it needs to be some symbol that the person registering people to vote can see so that they know whether it's legal to register them to vote.
I think that's in a nutshell.
I've heard some of the opposition, but I'm really, really not happy with being accused of being prejudicial because of non-citizens.
I've had friends, even family, who married into the family who were non-citizens.
They didn't become citizens after they'd been here like, oh, 20 years at least.
So I don't see that as a prejudicial thing.
The other thing that shocks most people when I talk to them is they can't believe that our real ID looks exactly like a non-citizen's real ID.
I didn't know that until I was reading the description of how to get a real ID, or that you can't use it when you're applying for a passport.
I'll take any questions.
Okay.
Thank you, Representative Gay.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, I let you up.
I let a question now, Representative Talersky.
I'm sorry, I'll be very quick.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Gay, I just wanna ask a quick question on the wording, how it says, including citizenship or legal residency.
So you're saying that this is for ease in voter registration, but if someone's a legal resident, it doesn't necessarily mean that they're a citizen and can vote.
So I guess I'm wondering why that is included.
I found out years ago working in a lab that it was always better to have something to look at than to look for the absence of something.
So one option would be using the absence method would just put some little symbol on a citizen, like an eagle or something.
Don't, you know, that's, I didn't put that in there for the reason.
So for a non-citizen, they should have a symbol too.
The only people who can have licenses are legally here in the United States.
So they're either citizens or when I was looking it up, they are non-citizens who are either temporary or considered terminate.
So they could have a symbol and then citizens could have a symbol.
Something that doesn't jump out at you, but that's distinguishable by the person doing the voter registration.
May I follow up, Mr.
Chair?
Yep, follow up.
So Representative Gay, what you're saying is that there would be one mark for a citizenship clarification and then another mark if someone is simply here with a driver's license but it's a legal resident.
Yes.
Okay so we're talking about two different markings that would indicate that these people are safe drivers but have different classifications.
Right.
Just of citizenship.
Yes.
Thank you.
There's a question.
but have different classifications.
Right, just of citizenship, yes.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Seeing none, thank you Representative Gaye.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm just going to go right down the list.
These are all in opposition.
So first, we look at looking for the chair recognizes Ken Barnes, representing himself, is opposed, is asking for zero time.
But as I said, I'll give everybody three minutes.
I do not see him.
If you could raise his hand, that would be helpful.
But other than that, I do not see Ken Barnes on there.
All right.
If you can keep an eye out for him, I'll check it out.
There's a possibility people signed in an error and hit the yes, not meaning to speak, but we'll keep an eye out for them.
Next would be Stephanie Bray, representing the Hampshire Legal Assistance, also opposed, asking to testify, also asking for zero minutes.
Stephanie Bray.
There she is.
Hold on one second, please.
You have three minutes.
Once we get you.
You're still muted.
Thank you.
This body wisely voted two years ago to ITL a very similar bill, House Bill 471.
Hold on.
Can you please, for the record, identify yourself?
I'm sorry.
Sure.
I'm Stephanie Bray, and I'm from New Hampshire Legal Assistance.
Thank you for your patience as I work my way through the technology.
We are requesting that the committee recommend ITL for this bill.
We do not mark people's driver's licenses with P for Protestant or C for Catholic or UU for Unitarian Universalist.
And that's because our state constitution and the federal constitution both require that there be equal protection of the law for all persons.
And what that means is a state law that singles people out based on citizenship or other immigration status is treated the same way as a state law that singles people out on the basis of religion.
It gets looked at, that law gets looked at with strict scrutiny.
And that has nothing to do with the personal qualifications or attitudes of the people behind the bill.
And I mean no accusation against Representative Gay, but a law that singles out people based on their immigration status would be, it would be challenged on the basis, is there a compelling reason for the law?
And is this solution narrowly tailored to solve the problem?
And there really wasn't a compelling reason for this bill in 2019.
There is really no compelling reason now.
If people go to register to vote, you only do that once, or you change your residency and move to another town, you do it again.
it's not a big burden to come up with what's necessary to demonstrate your citizenship and a driver's license isn't enough to do that anyway.
You're going to have to come up with a birth certificate.
So marking a driver's license with a flag for citizens and something else for non-citizens really does not achieve that purpose.
What it unfortunately would achieve, not through anyone's intention in passing the bill, but what it would achieve would be increased scrutiny on the people who hold the driver's license that doesn't have the eagle.
And that is very concerning.
And that's all I have.
And I yield the floor and welcome any questions.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you very much.
Have a great day.
Thank you.
Okay, down the list.
Chair recognizes Asma Aluni, lobbyist representing herself, opposed.
Did not seek any time, but same three minutes applies.
Once we can find her.
I do not see her.
If she could her hand if she's there.
So, Loni, if you're there, you need to raise your hand.
I don't see her on the attendee list either.
So, all right, I'll, I'm going to hold off.
We'll go back at the end for any of the ones that are on the list that we didn't get to uh next up the chair recognizes maggie fogerty um representing american friend service committee new hampshire also opposed to the bill miss fogerty if we can find you.
I do not see her either.
Well, I guess they were serious about zero minutes.
Mr.
Chairman, excuse me.
I see one of the people you called have their hand raised in the waiting room.
Which one is that?
Asma Elhouni.
Oh, okay.
I see now.
Thank you.
We'll go back.
Okay, there she is.
Need to unmute.
Asma Elhouni.
Can you hear me?
You can now.
Good morning.
Yeah, I had my hand raised when you asked me to raise my hand, so I'm wondering if that's happening with Maggie, too.
My name is Asmael Huni.
I am with Rights and Democracy New Hampshire, a grassroots organization that promotes human rights.
We stand strongly against HB 587.
This bill is not only racist, but also xenophobic and sends a dangerous message to our community members that New Hampshire is truly unwelcoming to immigrants.
As an immigrant myself, I'm appalled that such a bill is back up again in legislation.
Immigrants already have it hard, already being so different, and particularly immigrants of color, they're targeted and discriminated against, and this bill will make it likely for discrimination to continue to happen.
The defense of this bill is ridiculous, preposterous, and not substantial on any grounds whatsoever.
So, for example, when I go to a pharmacy and cashiers ask me because of age restrictions, like like items for cough syrup or cigarettes or alcohol, et cetera, that require a photo ID, that cashier should not be privy to my personal immigration status, right?
But this bill would give that information to her, right?
As far as voting, the Secretary of State knows our status.
When someone is registered to vote, they must present their social security number.
Right.
And so that that that is going to verify citizenship.
So if someone did present a fake ID, it's up to the secretary of state to confirm whether that person is registered to vote.
And it is indeed a citizen.
Right.
And so no other agency should be observing voter registration like that, because when we register to vote, they already make sure and they're not using our license as a form of ID.
They're using other things.
Also, additionally, there's no evidence in the state of New Hampshire where a non-citizen presented a fake ID to vote.
So we shouldn't be acting like this is a problem in our state.
So this bill singles out community members.
It is unnecessary and absolutely needs to be defeated just as it was defeated in 2019 for our community members in the state of New Hampshire.
Thank you very much.
If you want to take any questions.
Seeing none.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your testimony.
Should we try Maggie Fogarty again?
Representative O'Hara, if we can scan through this.
I am not seeing her.
Okay.
Well, we'll keep her checked off.
Chair recognizes Jean Husker from the ACL of New Hampshire, and I am here to testify in opposition to HB 587.
And we share the concerns previously expressed that the unintended consequence of this bill is to turn driver's licenses into tools of discrimination.
Driver's licenses are intended to enhance public safety.
They ensure that people operating motor vehicles are properly trained to do so.
They're not intended to denigrate people or apply a hierarchy to granite staters.
And yet if we add some sort of marking that says here's a group that are citizens and here's a group that's not, it sends a message that granite staters who carry and present licenses without the approved citizenship marking are somehow lesser than.
This bill invites discrimination by conveying citizenship on ID cards that are used nearly every day.
Vote, you vote once every two years, maybe once every four years.
Think of how often you present your driver's license for a whole host of other things, whether it's purchasing cigarettes or alcohol or going into events, whether it's at your bank, your pharmacy, when you rent a place and you show it to your landlord.
I get the election concern.
I don't agree with it, but I just really worry that you use licenses for so many other reasons and to be sharing immigration status for all of those other encounters.
We really worry about the discriminatory effect.
I'd also add that adding a citizenship requirement to obtaining a driver's license or ID card could actually increase the cost of doing so.
A U.S.
passport, which is the preferred form of proof of citizenship, costs $135 for a first-time applicant, which may help explain, by the way, why only 41 percent of Americans have one.
Birth certificates can be less expensive to obtain, but just as burdensome for Americans who have moved away from the state in which they were born.
Given the difficulty in obtaining proof of citizenship, it's inevitable that some Granite Staters will be unable to provide such documentation.
And I'd ask you, what happens at that point?
If a Granite Stater cannot afford a passport or procure their birth certificate, is the default to assume that they're a non-citizen?
Does that end up going on their driver's license?
Given how necessary driving is in our state, we should not be making it more difficult and expensive for granted staters to obtain a license.
And I would just note, again, going back to the crime sponsors discussion about elections, our governor and secretary of state have both applauded our elections, including the security of elections.
I have not heard a single concern from our secretary of state or from our governor about false driver's licenses or about difficulties in voters proving their citizenship for purposes of voting.
I will wrap up.
I don't see a problem that this bill solves and we really do worry that it'll actually create more problems.
So I appreciate the opportunity to testify and I'm happy to answer any questions.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none you again thank you mr chair chair recognizes viola katasumi i'm trying to pronounce it um katasimi uh representing the granite state organizing project opposed to the bill let me Let me see if I find her.
Okay.
You're still muted.
Hello?
I can hear you now.
Good morning, members of the committee.
Thank you so much for the opportunity to speak.
For the record, my name is Viola Tatsime.
I work for the Guardian State Organizing Project.
We are a grassroots non-partisan organization that brings faith, labor, and community groups to work towards a more just world.
I'm here to share my personal story and I'm also here to oppose HB 587.
As a law-abiding immigrant with legal status to live and work here, I don't see why this bill would be necessary on any ground.
Over the past five years, the level of tension has heightened against immigrants.
We have seen an increase in anti-immigrant incidents.
We have seen increased bias and discrimination.
Does this body want to endorse that, promote that, or encourage that behavior?
HB 587 is nothing other than a tool to promote discrimination and unfair treatment of immigrants who may come into contact with law enforcement and other government individuals with authority.
This bill is deliberately trying to create the other.
As an as an immigrant myself, I already feel that every day.
So why let us why did this really make us pit against each other further.
I, for one, know my rights.
And I know that with my status, I don't qualify for any government benefits.
And I'm happy that I have to work and contribute to society.
I know that I'm not eligible for it, but that doesn't stop me from educating the community and telling people about the importance of voting and turning out eligible voters.
The immigrants I know and that I encounter in my work understand that they are entitled to.
If you are a permanent resident, for instance, or a green card holder, or you are a non-temporary resident on a visa, you know what you're entitled to.
You know that you cannot afford.
So we know that they look pretty well as immigrants and what's available to us.
Dr.
King said, it's not so much what evil people do, but it's too often the silence of good people.
I want to draw a parallel here.
This policy would do no good but harm if we do nothing.
This is a moral moment, so I believe this body is full of good leaders who will do the right thing.
I'd like to believe that the people of New Hampshire don't want this law either.
I'm proud to say that I'm now a New Hampshire resident, and that's what matters for me.
So I want New Hampshire to be our coming state, so I want to urge committee members to vote in a city to legislate.
Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you very much.
I've seen no questions, so thank you again.
Have a good day.
Next up, Chair recognizes Grace Kendecki, representing American Friends Service Committee, opposed to the bill, only seeking two minutes, but in all fairness, you've got three.
Hello, can you hear me?
We can now.
Good morning.
Okay, good morning.
Thank you so much.
My hello and thank you to the committee for giving me the opportunity to speak.
My name is Grace Kendeke.
I'm the program coordinator with the American Friends Service Committee, an immigrant justice organization.
I grew up in New Hampshire after immigrating here at the age of two in 1989.
I have lived in Manchester for the majority of my life, and I am currently a legal permanent resident.
I am here in opposition to HB 587 because I believe that there is no good reason for this bill, which seeks to manufacture an issue around either voter or proving citizenship, but instead continues to perpetuate an othering of immigrant granted staters.
To be an immigrant is to be acutely aware of your immigration status.
The penalty for claiming citizenship when you are not a citizen is very steep, and there's no good reason to do so.
That this bill comes up as a matter of convenience will have very untoward and unintended consequences that will contribute to New Hampshire becoming an increasingly unwelcome place for the thousands of immigrant families, communities, and taxpayers of which I am one.
Driver's licenses are used to establish photo ID and residency.
When I came to the U.S., I traveled with an original copy of my birth certificate.
In my 33 years of life, my family has been able to keep my birth certificate in a safe and a convenient place to be pulled out when needed.
Immigration status changes.
It's fluid.
And since I've been legally eligible to drive, I myself have held three different immigration statuses based on where I was in my process.
I urge the committee to vote to inexpedient to legislate this bill because it does not do what it says it does.
It will instead make immigrants like myself continue to feel what we already feel acutely as others are unwelcome in the state.
Thank you.
And I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you again.
Have a good day.
Thank you.
Oh, I made a mistake.
I do apologize.
Representative Perez, if I had seen you there earlier, I would have called you earlier, because I'm sure you're very busy today as well.
Representative Perez?
Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity to speak.
I'm against this bill.
As an immigrant, this is an assault to our rights.
To be honest, I've been listening to the testimonies, and one thing that I can say, from my own experience, to register for the first time when I registered to vote.
I was sent home three times before I can register to vote.
I went to my own town hall with my driver's license.
I was asked if I was a U.S.
citizen and I said yes I am a U.S.
citizen but I wasn't born here.
They sent me back home to go get my citizenship.
I went back home brought my my citizenship.
That wasn't good enough for them.
I went back home, brought my U.S.
passport.
So not even I brought my driver's license, my U.S.
passport, and my citizenship in order for me to register to vote.
So when I heard people saying that this is going to help us to register to vote, it's an immigrant, this is an assault.
This is not going to fix anything.
This is going to help people to discriminate for people for the legal status.
I go to the pharmacy and pick up medicine.
I just put myself in the shoes of other immigrants.
I go to the pharmacy once or twice a week.
Thank you.
I go to the pharmacy and pick up medicine.
I just put myself in the shoes of other immigrants.
I go to the pharmacy once or twice a week.
Do you imagine people going to the pharmacy to pick up the medicine and have that stand like saying, oh, you're not a U.S.
citizen, you are a resident?
That gives people the rights to discriminate against people because of the color or because of the accent, because of the way they look.
We don't need any more lots and new hunches to let people discriminate because of your skin color, because of the way you look.
I'll oppose this bill, and I will ask every single one of you to oppose this bill.
And thank you for your time.
Thank you, Representative.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you again.
Chair recognized Bruno Soares, member of the public, representing Catholic Charities New Hampshire, opposed to the bill.
See if we can bring him up.
Hello.
Good morning, sir.
Good morning, Mr.
Chair.
Good morning, all of the members of the committee.
My name is Bruno Sorris.
I'm an advocate at Catholic Church New Hampshire, and I'm here to oppose and urge you to oppose HB 587.
And the reason being is because this bill is nothing but for discriminatory purposes.
Representative Betty Gray claims that only citizens and lawful permanent residents can apply for a driver's license in the state.
But there are other categories of immigrants who are allowed to apply for driver's license in the state.
The Deferred Action for Childhood Arrivals, known as DACA, is one of them.
TPS, Temporary Protective Status, is another one.
Pending Asylum applicants are also in other categories, among many others.
I also would like to point out and clarify one of the things that was said today, that the effect of driver's license for identification purposes.
Although we do use driver's license for identification purposes, the statute only permits the driver's license to tell the status that the person is eligible to drive.
So I would like to direct you to RSA 263 1C, which states that a driver's license issued by the state of New Hampshire is a written declaration to the holder of permission to operate a motor vehicle.
So that's the effect of a driver's license in the state.
And the biggest concern that Representative Betty Gay had was that voting fraud.
So I just would like to point out that she she's targeting the wrong class by simply.
Please, please don't assume what she's trying to do, sir.
Okay.
So by providing in-laws citizenship status on the application.
But in the past, the people that actually have committed voting fraud in the state of New Hampshire, they were U.S.
citizens.
So most recently, 2020, we had Charles Eugene Cordier Jr.
of Madison, New Hampshire.
We had 2020, Mary Lunds, 57, of Washington, D.C., charged for double voting in New Hampshire.
2016, Vincent Marcelo, 65 of West Lebanon, charged with double voting in New Hampshire.
2016, John and Grace Fleming of Hampton, charged with double voting in New Hampshire.
So, unfortunately, you know, we are trying to target the wrong category of people who actually has never, there's no indication.
Sorry, I'm just trying to keep it fair for everybody.
Your time's run up.
If you can, I'll give you an opportunity for a closing statement.
Thank you.
Yeah, so the wrong category for people that actually has never, and there's no indication that has committed voting fraud in the state of New Hampshire.
So thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you again for your testimony.
Chair recognizes Louise Spencer, a member of the public representing herself, also opposed to the bill.
Let's see if we can find her here.
I do not see her.
If she could raise her hand if she's in the queue.
Louise Spencer is, I don't see her on the attendee list either.
I'll give her a last call when we're done.
Move on.
Chair recognizes Christine Wellington, member of the public representing herself, opposed to the bill.
Seeking five minutes, but I'm going to keep it fair.
Three, please.
Good morning.
Can everybody hear me?
We can now.
Good morning, Chair Walsh and members of the Transportation Committee.
I'm Christine Wellington.
I'm here also on behalf of the Immigrants Rights Network.
And this morning, I apologize, we should have sent it yesterday afternoon, but I did send a letter from the Immigrants Rights Network that outlines our opposition to this Bill 587.
And we're asking for the committee to vote an inexpedient to legislate.
Our primary concern is the topic of violation of constitutional protections that both citizens and non-citizens possess.
And my former colleague, Attorney Stephanie Bray from New Hampshire Legal Assistance, went over all of the reasons why we believe that this unintentional consequence of this bill would be to trigger constitutional concerns.
I would also want to point out that as as Ms.
Fresca from the ACLU did, that immigration status and citizenship status is a fluid position, so any marking on a state license, even if it was legal, which we say it would not be, would be only accurate on the day that that applicant checked off a particular box.
I also understand that Representative Gay's idea was that this would be more convenient for folks if there was a marking on the license as to eligibility to vote.
I did have the opportunity to speak with Sherry Farrell, who is the town clerk of Londonderry and also the president of the New Hampshire Association of City and Town Clerks.
She said that they do not use driver's licenses to prove that somebody is a citizen of the United States.
And she also said that she is not personally aware or has been made aware by members of the 234 cities and towns in New Hampshire of any concerns with immigrants voting or using driver's licenses to attempt to vote.
So she thought that this was a non-issue.
One of the other things this bill asks is for the DMV to collect information based on citizenship.
The DMV already does that.
I did attach to the letter we submitted a copy of the DMV application form for both driver's licenses and non-driver IDs.
And you'll see that it has a checkoff box.
The DMV also participates in the SAVE program, which is operated by the United States Citizen and Immigration Services, which can verify immigration status fairly instantaneously.
Ms.
Wellington, can I give you an opportunity for a closing statement?
Thank you, Chair.
I think I've covered, the only thing I would also wanna say is that the term legal residency does not cover all the classes of people that are eligible for driver's licenses in New Hampshire.
And I'd ask, again, ask the committee to vote ITL.
Thank you.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you again.
I'm seeing a couple of hands come up.
Chair recognizes Representative Elizabeth Toll.
Good afternoon.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Yep.
My name is Amanda Elizabeth Toll, and I represent Keene at Large.
I oppose HB 587.
This bill requires that driver's license and non-driver's identification cards indicate whether or not the holder is a citizen of the United States.
This bill may be coming before the Transportation Committee.
However, I, and I believe the majority of my constituents, know this bill really has racist and xenophobic implications.
It will surely result in an increase in Black and brown people being detained and possibly deported, and will disrupt our immigrant communities.
In 2017, New Hampshire resident Eliezer Lopez Aiella, a husband and father who had lived and worked in the United States for 25 years and had no criminal record, had a flat tire.
A simple flat tire led to being detained by ICE and threatened with deportation.
On Thanksgiving of 2017, hundreds of people from my city of Keene organized in opposition to his deportation.
My city has also had very large turnouts for the Black Lives Matter protests in the wake of George Floyd's murder.
My constituents have shown time and time again that they reject racism and xenophobia in all forms.
I am here today to represent the citizens of Keene in strong opposition to this bill.
I will not be taking questions.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Chair recognizes Representative Horrigan.
I've been added as a panelist.
Okay.
Yes.
So I'm representing Timothy who are going to represent Drafat County district six, which is the towns of Durham and Madbury.
And Durham, as a college town, has more non-citizens with various immigration statuses than other towns would.
And then some of them, and the fact that they're, and some of them probably do have New Hampshire driver's licenses because the driver's license, you know, it's a license to drive and it's also it's a state function, whereas immigration is a federal function.
So we don't necessarily.
So the fact that you're there and you have a motor and you tend to drive a motor vehicle is separate from whether how it is that you got their immigration status.
So that's, and my concern stems from a somewhat related another hot question issue, which is EBT cards, which I've been working on off and on for 10 years.
We've had incidents with people being sort of appointing themselves or deputy, you know, health and human services officials who just clerks and stuff.
And like you had started with an issue 10 years ago with a man who didn't have a better we call non-visible disability but still had disability benefits and she wouldn't let him use the car and tell him to get a job and stuff and this could happen with the driver's licenses uh driver's licenses too because you often have to present them for people who are not with the dV or not law enforcement and they could sort of appoint themselves junior ICE agents to start challenging people because they think the citizen status on the card is incorrect or that they shouldn't be there so it's best to just not have it on the driver's license and also since the driver's license is issued because you're a resident regardless of like why it is how it is you came to be living here what your citizen did as others have said immigration status is fluid it changes a lot for the person it's still the same person including in some cases uh people have driver's licenses actually get to take the pledge and get to have the honor of becoming u.s citizens but they may still have their own driver's license without the little marking on it.
So that would be especially humiliating for those people if somebody started challenging their citizenship for the right to be here.
So I think we should keep that.
I think we should just, you know, the driver's license is for the purpose of proving that you're licensed to drive, and then it's also secondarily used as a picture ID.
So it's not a guarantee guarantee of immigration status and there's other documents people use to prove what their citizenship is or what their immigration status is so i think uh i think this bill is it was unnecessary it causes it solves a non-existent problem and it will cause lots of problems so i recommend that you find it an expedient to legislate so a lot.
I hope I added something from what the other people have said.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you again, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thanks.
I see one more hand.
Chair recognizes Kelly Briniac with the New Hampshire Division of Motor Vehicles, and we are neutral to this bill, but did want to point out the limited amount of real estate that the DMV currently has on all types of New Hampshire driver licenses and non-driver IDs.
I believe our director did send samples to the chair, and that's it for me today, but I am happy to answer any questions.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Representative O'Hara?
Yeah, this is speaking to Matt's point last night.
Can we get a sample of the bath also?
I believe the director did send that, but if you did not, we can certainly resend it to the chair.
Thank you.
That's it.
You're welcome.
I believe it was only for the front.
We'll take care of that.
Thank you.
Seeing no questions, thank you again for your testimony.
I see another hand raised.
Chair recognizes Ann Grossi.
Good morning, my name is Ann Grossi, Can you hear me?
You can.
Good afternoon.
Sorry.
You already received my written testimony, so I will not go into that, other than to say that I live in Bedford, New Hampshire, and my daughter-in-law is from Thailand and is now a U.S.
citizen.
I just want to reiterate what one of the speakers said is that when she went to obtain her license, she had a green card at the time.
So the DMV did collect that information and does already have that information.
And she is now a U.S.
citizen.
She obtained her citizenship in October of 2020.
And when she went to vote in Bedford, she could not just present her license.
She had to have her certificate of naturalization.
So this bill seems to assume that immigrants are going to go and try to vote with merely a license.
And to me, Bedford, I'm sure is like every other town, they will not merely take a license.
They have to have something that will prove citizenship.
She showed her certificate of naturalization with great deal of pride so that she knew that she was now a citizen and could vote.
And I hope that this bill is opposed and will not be voted in in any shape, me, or form because it merely stigmatizes immigrants.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
committee seeing none thank you again uh i'm going to return one in all fairness one last call to louise spencer you see her name come up represent i do not see it if she's in there she could raise her hand but other than that i do not see her okay we tried um that is everybody i have signed up to speak we have no more hands raised so with that uh well i will let you know typically i go through the list of people that have just signed in uh it's extensive it's multiple pages so i'm just going to put this one in the file uh if you're interested uh obviously that's available to anybody so with that i'm going to close the public hearing on house bill 587.
next hearing will be at one o'clock house bill 496 enjoy your lunch thank you Obrigado.
Thank you.
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right.
I'm going to open the public hearing on House Bill 496 relative to license plate covers.
Representative Pearson.
There we go.
How about now?
Do we have a copy here?
Yep.
We can hear you now, sir.
Good afternoon, Representative.
Thank you very much, honorable colleagues.
I come before you with House Bill 496.
For those of you that were on transportation in the last session, this bill should look relatively familiar to you as we did some work to make some changes to the bill that was filed a year ago.
Basically the premise of this bill involves Thank you.
to make some changes to the bill that was filed a year ago.
Basically the premise of this bill involves the recent popularity, I guess you will, of license plate covers that are not just there for the purpose of protecting the license plate, but are there to obscure the license plate.
And this is really something that has kind of exploded around here in the past several years so the the purpose of house bill 496 is to add some clarity into a current section of law that already exists under 261 semi-colon 176 because it's already against the law to obscure in a way a license plate in the sense that under the statute it states that you cannot normally obscure or permit to be obscured the figures or letters on a plate the problem is is that in discussions with my friends in law enforcement they found that that was a little bit ambiguous in the sense that they were getting arguments on the side of the road from people saying, look, you can read this just fine.
And the reality is, is that the overwhelming majority of states have addressed this issue.
And I sent each of you an email with my testimony and presentation, along with some photographs.
And I think the photographs are really the kind of the key to all this.
When you take into account, especially in one photograph where the plate of the vehicle that's right next to you, you can't even read, but you can read the plate of the vehicle that's in front of it.
So that's really the, the gist of this.
The, you know, ultimately the point of a license plate is to identify a vehicle.
And when one obscures that, they're separating themselves from the intent here.
It was interesting in my research of all of this with what the various states allow and do not allow that Channel 4 in New York had actually done a bit of an expose on it in 2014 as a result of people running to the toll plazas and obscuring their license plates so that the toll readers would not be able to function.
So I'm not going to read you the whole list of what every state does.
It's in the email I sent you guys, but it really does show that the overwhelming majority of the states have some sort of prohibition on this in some manner.
And interestingly enough, I'll point out the state of Oklahoma, a state I lived in when I was in college.
They will actually pull a vehicle over that is from out of state that has a plate that is covered or obscured.
And they're the only one that I could find of the states within their statute that specifically said they would pull over vehicles from another state.
Typically we have, we just don't do that when it comes to some things that are permitted in one state versus another.
But Oklahoma actually found this to be such a problem that they were willing to put it into their statute that vehicles from out of state would be cited as well.
So that's the gist of this.
And, um, I hope you guys all have a chance to look over the email I sent out and, and the, um, the examples and the photographs as to really what's going on.
And I, and the other thing I ask is that in the next few days before, um, if there's time period between now and the exec session that you just, just pay attention just a little bit.
These things are everywhere.
And Thank you, sir.
Representative Talarski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative Pearson.
I don't know if you remember, but last term I was opposed.
I voted against your bill and I'm hoping you can convince me otherwise this time, because I appreciate what you're trying to do.
And I agree with you that obscuring the plates is a problem.
My issue with it was that the statute as it stands already states that you can't obscure your plate.
You can't knowingly obscure it.
So my question is, if you put any color plate, clear or tinted, cover, excuse me, any color cover, clear or tinted over your plate, which we all know will get covered in grime and potentially obscure the legibility of the plate.
Isn't any plate cover that's placed going to be knowingly possibly obscuring it?
Thank you for the question, Representative.
I mean, realistically, you know, in the inspection standard in the state, it mentions, you know, that license plates have to be legible and clean.
And that's something that is certainly true.
But there is a, I think, in the land of sand and salt, you know, we have folks that have, you know, we're one of the most popular vanity plate states in the United States per capita.
And, you know, we have folks that will put completely translucent protective covers on these plates and those don't obscure.
Now, certainly if they get dirty, they do, but that would hold true for a license plate even if it didn't have a cover on it.
Any other questions?
Actually, I do.
Okay, I have nobody else signed up to speak, so I'll ask a question.
I heard you say that this, I thought I heard you say, maybe you can correct me, that this is different than the bill from last year.
If so, if I heard that right, can you explain for that one more time for clarity and so what the outcome for everybody's memory with the bill last year sure thank you sir the the original language of 14-0 something or other it was last time involved a scale, if you will.
The original language requested that the covers be 100 clear or translucent i can't remember which which was used and there was a tremendous amount of discussion in reference to to that number being being such a definitive number of 100 so the committee asked that that be removed and an amendment was brought forward.
And so the language was changed.
And then the bill was passed through committee.
It made it through the house and it got caught in all the, as we're all aware, the magnificent disaster that the Senate brought forward at the end of last year.
So the committee, like I said, last session, was happy with the changes that were made, and this reflects the changes that were requested by transportation in the bill in the prior session.
Thank you.
Any further questions from the committee?
Representative Sykes?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Pearson, how are you today?
I'm exhausted.
I had Zoom going in two hands yesterday, simultaneously.
Some days are like that.
Yes, they are.
Why wouldn't it be just clearer to say any person who applies or permits to be applied any covering to a license plate that obscures the plate shall be guilty of a violation.
Why?
How is it helpful just to call out colored, smoked, and tinted?
And then leaving open the question of, well, if it's something other than that, it's okay to do it.
The only thing I can think of that would be other than that would be translucent.
So, you know, this is, these people don't make these things in their garages.
These are things you would buy at an auto parts store.
And that's the variety of covers that you can, at this point in time, you can purchase tinted covers, you can purchase ones that change the color of your plate, and you can purchase ones that are like I said completely clear.
And that's so I pretty much covered the the spectrum with that.
I'm not aware of any other type of cover that doesn't fit that those three categories.
Okay thank you for thank you for taking the question.
Further questions?
Thank you very much, Representative.
Thank you guys and I wish you all to be on schedule as my committees have struggled tremendously.
We're close.
we're close okay representative o'Hara, for some reason I can't split my screen.
Do we have any hands up for people wishing to speak?
I do not see any.
Okay, thank you, sir.
What's that?
If there are no hands up, I have nobody else signed up.
Representative Terlorski just raised her hand.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Mr.
Chairman, is it possible that we could see if there's anyone in the room from the Department of Safety who could maybe clarify if they believe that this bill um makes it even clearer about the obscuring the license plate yeah well we can look and i'll certainly try to get my screen split but if it helps uh captain haynes from department of safety uh an office of highway safety did sign in in support of it they're just they didn't want to testify uh ben hampshire Association of Chiefs of Police, Elizabeth Sargent, also signed in in support of it they're just they didn't want to testify uh the new hampshire association of chiefs of police elizabeth sergeant also signed in in support did not want to testify uh and our friend eric rathbun uh once again has signed in in support but we can certainly see if she's on the line sergeant kelby miss sergeant kelby has his hand up.
Okay, great.
Sergeant.
Hello?
Hello.
Sorry about that.
I just, my computer just seems to have turned off there.
I apologize.
Representative Flursky, I raised my hand when you asked about that.
Mr.
Chairman, may I rephrase my question to, um, Sergeant?
Thank you.
Sergeant Kelp?
Yes, ma'am.
Um, I'm just wondering if you feel this bill, um, specifying the coloring of the, of the plate cover helps clarify what's already in statute, um, or if you feel it muddies the water a little bit.
Thank you.
the of the plate cover helps clarify what's already in statute or if you feel it muddies the water a little bit.
So in looking at 261-176 and the change in the in the verbiage you know as paragraph two I think it does clear it up.
Paragraph one does say, bear with me as I read this from my iPad, knowingly or deliberately fails to display on a via, I'm sorry, any person who knowingly attacks or permits to be attached to a vehicle number played assigned by the department or authority of any other jurisdiction to any, to another vehicle or who knowingly obscures or permits to be obscured the figures or letters.
I think that clarifies it.
The color part doesn't really concern me because the paragraph two does add it.
I guess this is just asking more for if you want to put a plate cover on it, is it permissible?
And this does clarify it.
I do recall last year this bill, and I do remember the discussion on opacity and, you know, as far as, you know, what light transmittance was required.
I think this clarifies it.
So I don't really have a concern with it because it does say, in essence, it has to be clear.
And paragraph one does say it cannot be obscured.
So road salt, which would have been my concern, debris like driving today to get yet another COVID test, you know, getting on the license plate cover would be covered under paragraph one.
That would be a violation of the law.
So I think this allows people to have their plate cover and it also, you know, clearly spells out what's permissible or not.
May I ask a follow-up, Mr.
Chair?
Follow-up.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sergeant Kelby.
That helps.
I am curious, do you pull over or are people spoken to, would you say equally for obscured license plates due to just grime right on the license plate or also grime on the cover?
Do you think it's a pretty equal regardless of if you have a cover or not?
I would think so.
I've stopped cars for having snow on their bumper covering the license plate.
I've stopped cars for having colored license plate covers.
And I have stopped cars for having the damaged clear damaged clear plates, because you just can't see the plate.
And even a comment to the representative that spoke earlier on the bill, the law permits, you know, police officers in the state of New Hampshire to stop any vehicle that has an obscured plate.
It doesn't matter what state they're from.
It specifically says or another jurisdiction.
So I think it's probably fair to say that any, you know, any obscurement would be, you know, reason to stop.
I think it would be equal across the board.
Thank you.
That helps me very much.
Okay.
Any other questions?
No, the committee.
Seeing none.
Thank you, Sergeant, for your help.
I was originally going to, well, first of all, nobody else signed up to speak.
No more hands raised, Representative O'Hara?
I do not see any.
Okay.
Thank you, sir.
And I've already read you the three people that have signed in in support of the bill.
With that, I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 496.
I was hoping to exec this today, but I've got a question raised now, too, that I want to look into.
We probably still barely have enough time, but I also don't want to get behind right off the gate this afternoon.
So I'm not going to, even though I was originally thinking of going to bring up the executive session on this today.
That being said, we'll be back at 1.30 for our next hearing on House Bill 175.
Thank you.
you I did that just getting back here.
Yeah.
Sound check.
Representative Hill, can you hear me?
I can indeed.
Thank Hill, can you hear me?
Thank you, sir.
I can't hear Vice Chair Gagne, though.
How schnell!
Now I can.
Okay.
Alrighty, I'm going to open up the public hearing on house bill 175, an act relative to reciprocal driver education.
We have representative Comtois.
I just promoted her.
I don't know where she is now.
It was just there.
Hold on one second, please.
There she is.
Okay.
Hello.
Can you hear me now?
You can.
Good afternoon, representative.
Good afternoon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee for hearing my testimony on this.
The constituent who is going to testify here today and the reason this bill was brought forward is ill and cannot be here.
So I'm going to basically run through why this bill came about and why it is needed.
A constituent contacted me back in April of 2020.
She had been trying to get her son a driver's license who had completed driver's ed in North Carolina.
He has a certificate of completion of the driver's ed.
And in October of 2019, she contacted the DMV and talked to the clerks.
And they told her to come on up to apply for his license.
In December of 2019, she went to the Tamworth DMV, and they told her that she was given misinformation because the North Carolina driver's education would not be accepted.
She then went and spoke to the supervisor of the driver's education, State Policewoman Stephanie Bosch on January 2nd.
She waited.
She followed up on January 14th with Ms.
Bosch, who said and then asked for her supervisor.
Long and short of it, until she got a hold of me, no one returned her calls.
The young man in question had completed his driver's ed training in North Carolina.
They moved here because they were in the military, so they had moved to New Hampshire.
If he was able to get his driver's license in North Carolina at the time, when they moved to New Hampshire, he could have just applied for a New Hampshire driver's license with no issues.
I contacted the DMV and spoke with Commissioner Balicki's assistant, the director's assistant.
And they got ahold of Ms.
Bodie, which she was very grateful for.
And the RSA, as currently written, says that they have the ability to waive the requirement and let the person go forth and take the New Hampshire driver's education test.
when I tell you that this woman for six months worked to try and get her son a driver's education tried to find out what she needed to do with no response until she contacted me in April.
And then her son did not get his driver's education license until July because the difference in the requirement between North Carolina and New Hampshire was four driving hours.
Four.
Now, he had been driving for over six months now, supervised with his parents.
I don't know how many other people that this is affecting, but because he moved to New Hampshire, he still had to take the New Hampshire driver's education test, which means he had to understand our laws.
He had to pass the driver's education driving part of it.
And they wouldn't wait four hours.
Now, if he was 16 and came here, you can take that and you don't have to know the New Hampshire driver's laws because you don't have to retake a test you just get a new license.
So I ask why we don't make driver's education reciprocal across state lines and I'd be more than happy to answer any questions from the committee members.
Questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much Representative.
Thank you.
Okay.
Chair recognizes Sharon Cameron, representing New Hampshire Driver Education Teachers Association.
We can find Sharon Camber.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
The New Hampshire Drivers Education Teachers Association opposes House Bill 175.
The DMV already has a system in place to evaluate other states' programs and ensure public safety on our roads by insisting on standards equivalent to New Hampshire requirements.
What the DMV already does works very well and New Hampshire DITA doesn't support nor see a need for changes to the system.
I have in fact personally participated in helping families who move here finish their students' driver education requirements.
I can't speak to the student from North Carolina and the issues that they had with the DMV, but I've participated a lot in this program, and it's always worked very smoothly for us.
Thank you for the opportunity to speak today.
I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Thank you very much.
Seeing none, thank you again.
Thank you.
Mr.
Chair, Representative Gorski has his hand up.
Thank you.
Representative Gorski.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I did have a question for Ms.
Cameron.
She's still on.
Let's see if she's still there.
I didn't see you.
I apologize.
Are you still there?
Yes.
Ms.
Cameron, thank you for your testimony.
Thank you for taking my question.
Can you describe briefly when there is someone coming from out of state, you know, a young teenager who, you know, has to go through this process, can you describe the process, kind of how it works?
Absolutely.
So I live on the border of New Hampshire and Vermont, and this kind of comes up a lot in our area.
I also live near Dartmouth College and the hospital.
So folks, families seem to come and go in this area fairly frequently.
So generally what happens is a parent will call me or the DMV and I direct them to the DMV to get approval for whatever their program is from their home state.
And they vary widely across the country.
And so once they get the approval from the DMV, then they just have to come to me.
They usually send me the email that says what the requirements are, four hours of driving, six hours of observation, almost never classroom time.
I think the DMV requires the 30 hours of classroom time regardless of the state and I expected perhaps that Director Bilecki would be here today and be able to speak to that.
But then all I have to do is finish up the hours with the student following the same rules that we follow for all the other New Hampshire students and then issue them a green certificate so that they can go to the DMV and get their license.
Thank you.
Questions?
Seeing none, thank you again.
That's all I've got for people signed up to speak.
Representative O'Hare, if you can look at some raised hands, if anybody else wishes to speak.
Is there anybody here from the Department of Motor Vehicles that would like to chime in?
Richard Dupont has his hand up.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Well, that was interesting.
My name is Trooper Richard DuPont, and I represent the New Hampshire Division of Motor Vehicles and the New Hampshire Department of Safety.
I am the supervisor of the driver education program for the state of New Hampshire, and thank you for the opportunity to allow me to speak with you today.
I speak in opposition to House Bill 175 as it speaks to RSA 26320 in the general acceptance of any driver education program developed by another state.
As in New Hampshire, each individual state has developed a driver education program which centers around what that particular state legislature deemed important for the safety of their young drivers and for those traveling upon their roadways.
Each state has their own unique geography.
I think we can all agree weather conditions and so on that require different lessons to be taught.
So each program is different for state to state.
In the past, the New Hampshire state legislature spoke to the quality of our state's program and what that program should look like and can be found in part in RSA 263 colon 19, which is driver's education.
The state legislature together with the New Hampshire Driver Education Association, which you just listened to Ms.
Cameron, the New Hampshire Department of Education and the New Hampshire Division of Motor Vehicles developed a quality program to have certified instructors and at certified schools teach our young drivers how to properly and safely operate a motor vehicle upon the roadways in New Hampshire.
This program has been successful for many years.
Part of the responsibility of our office is to review and process the request for the transfer of out-of-state driver education programs in keeping with RSA 263 colon 20, which of course is the subject of this hearing.
The process for these transfer requests is fairly straightforward, but is a task which our office takes seriously because of the safety of the drivers on our roadways is of the utmost importance, especially the young drivers.
It's been my experience as the supervisor of driver's education that not all driver education programs are the same.
And speaking with my counterparts and driving education instructors from other states, some require less class hours, less behind the wheel time, less driving at night, and less if any observation time, which is where a student driver observes and critiques another student driver as it is required in New Hampshire.
The classroom instruction from state to state in some states can be completed either in an actual classroom or reviewed or by viewing online videos or by a parent or guardian.
And their programs do not always contain mandated content, which the state of New Hampshire has deemed important as can be found in RSA 26319.
There is one state that actually doesn't even require a driver education program to obtain a license, which of course is a problem on different levels, but not really the subject of today's hearing.
The process currently in place because of RSA 26320 allows for the review of a young driver's out-of-state driver education program and that would be compared to the quality program for the state of New Hampshire.
I would like to apologize for this person that did have this issue and that's young driver.
That is not typically the way that it works in in our office, I can assure you of that.
The turnaround time can take up to two weeks.
But typically, not typically the way that it works in our office.
I can assure you of that.
The turnaround time can take up to two weeks, but typically it's much less than that, maybe about a week to turn around these types of out-of-state transfer requests.
I've handled probably five or six just last year from North Carolina, their program is slightly different.
To address the driving time discrepancy, the state of New Hampshire requires 10 hours.
Is that enough time?
I don't know, but our state legislature said that it is.
And to have it even less than that, now six hours, is not, you know, it's not in keeping with our driving program.
And it actually having those additional four hours ensures that these drivers, these young drivers are actually safe or safer, right, in theory, on our roadways.
We all read about it in the newspapers how young drivers are getting into accidents, and unfortunately, fatalities result from some of these.
And I think to have an out-of-state program be allowed just as a general rule, I don't think is a very good idea.
The language in RSA 26320, in closing, should not be changed.
To allow the general acceptance of another state's driver education program would not only create a double standard for our young drivers here in New Hampshire, because they're going to be held to a higher standard.
And this allowing out-of-state driver education drivers, it could potentially create unsafe roadways here in the state of New Hampshire.
With that, I want to say thank you, and I will take any questions.
Sir, question for Representative Hill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you for taking my question.
I've wanted to ask this for a long time, and I'm going to take the opportunity if I could.
Sure.
Is there any distinction when you're transferring driver ed from one part of the country to another that takes into account driving on snow and ice.
I've often wondered why we don't do something for those, even New Hampshire drivers, young drivers that take their driver ed in July and August and we don't ever teach them or have them drive in snowy weather.
And I wondered if that would be something that would be useful in your eyes.
If you're asking for my opinion, then yes, I think that absolutely, this is New England.
We have very unique weather.
And I can tell you as a police officer, the first storm snow storm of every year.
That's the worst storm, typically.
And I think most police officers will agree more.
There's more vehicles off the road.
I mean, people forget how to drive in the winter months and they forget how to drive on the snow.
And it's kind of crazy.
And your first snow, first couple of snow storms are more, not accidents, but they're pulling people out of the ditch, out of a snow bank, because they forget that I can't do a hundred down the highway or, or in this case, right, the speed limit.
And they drive unsafely.
And so why we don't have that in our program and have it mandated, I can't answer to that.
I cannot speak to that.
I do know that if, in my opinion, that if you required student drivers to actually drive in the winter months, then that just extends the program in the amount of time that young drivers would actually be getting their license.
I don't have an answer for you, but I mean, is it a good idea?
Of course, more more driving experience is better, but thank you, sir.
Actually, we're getting a little off track here, but we have talked about that simulators that you can actually even teach people how to drive in the snow in the middle of July.
But that's a topic for another day.
Next hand up I saw was Representative Aaron.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Mr.
DuPont, for your testimony today.
So I guess I'm a little puzzled with this requirement because, I mean, when people come here driving here from other states, we assume that they know what they're doing and they're behind the wheel.
There's no extra testing or extra documentation required or anything.
I guess I'm not sure why that would make a difference in terms of driver's ed between states.
You know, it seems to me programs are pretty much the same.
Is that not true?
Or is that false?
Well, with all due respect, ma'am, I did list some things that are different, and it has been my experience.
I did speak to the fact that each state has their own unique program, and they're not all, in fact, the same.
And as I said, Alaska doesn't even require a driver's ed program, but that's a different subject.
I mean, that leads to a different area.
So every state is different.
And if you're looking at the difference between, I'm presuming a licensed driver versus an unlicensed driver, then I think that in my opinion, there's a huge difference.
There can be a huge difference because now it's an inexperienced driver versus a person that already has a license and has some legitimate life experience on the roadway versus a student that a young driver that has no license doesn't have a lot of driving experience.
Maybe they do with a parent, but not on their own.
And that license actually gives them the opportunity to drive on their own.
So there is a difference in the two types of a licensed driver versus an unlicensed driver.
Hopefully that answered your question, ma'am.
Somewhat.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Next up, Representative Talersky.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
This seems like a very limited situation where you would have a teen take driver's ed in a state, then relocate before getting their license.
Can you tell me about how many transfer requests your office sees in a year?
Ma'am, I do not have an exact number.
I wasn't anticipating that question, but I would say that last year, our office handled between 20 and 30 out of state transfer requests.
I have actually eight sitting in my laptop here waiting for some final documentation.
and you know um typical part of this process um is is to just verify that, for one thing, that certificate from the other school is actually even a valid certificate.
And I guess the process is fairly easy.
But, again, all states are different, and we handle about 30 of these transfers a year, or at least we did last year.
Thank you very much.
Okay, thank you.
Representative O'Hara.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, Thank you, Mr.
Dupont for taking my question.
I just had one quick question.
If a child is 16 in Florida, they get their license and then immediately move up here.
Is there any requirements for them?
They need to provide that they have actually taken a driver's education program.
That is...
Sorry, man.
Can I follow up real quick?
Yes.
No, go ahead.
Yes, thank you.
So they, but they wouldn't be withheld, like their license wouldn't be withheld from them.
They would just have to prove that they took driver's ed down in Florida and then they would get a license up here in New Hampshire.
Sir, different states have different graduated licenses.
So it would depend on the type of license.
Typically, it doesn't have any other stipulations attached to it, but some licenses are a graduated license where they can only drive during certain hours and I've handled a few of those as well.
Fortunately for those people that were making the request it was a it was an actual easy swap one for one because of the type of license that they had but but when those requests come in you really need to, and I think the DMV does a good job at this, is to make sure that the restrictions on those licenses, because the youth licenses typically have some sort of restrictions, that they're similar to our license here in the state of New Hampshire.
Did that answer your question, sir?
Yeah, it did.
Yep, you're welcome.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Did that answer your question, sir?
Yeah, it did.
You're welcome.
Thanks.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Trooper, isn't it true that the whole reason for driver's education and the reciprocity questions that have come up is that we are trying to protect the most valuable one of the most valuable resources we have in the state which is the the youth of this state and that they as a class typically have a somewhat higher percentage of motor vehicle incidents based on their inexperience.
I would agree with that, sir.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Everett.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you again, Mr.
DuPont.
So in thinking about the state discrepancies and training that you described, how hard is it or would it be for someone to find an instructor here to provide the instruction for the areas that were lacking?
So in the example of Representative Pantois' presentation, she was saying that the person in question had four hours of training to make up.
How difficult would it be to find an instructor to just teach those four hours?
Ma'am, typically it's not that hard.
There are a lot of schools out there that are, they're busy, but I haven't found, in my experience, any student that really couldn't find a school to, that would provide that period of instruction for them, that drive time.
If I'm reading the timeline right, this occurred sometime in April of 2020.
And wouldn't that have been around the, you know, the onset of the COVID-19 virus?
If that's the case, around that timeframe, there were some schools that, you know, because the guidelines were, or we'll just say because of the COVID-19, some schools decided not to continue teaching driver's education, even though the governor's office deemed that driver's education was an essential business in the state of New Hampshire, and they could continue to do classroom.
But it wasn't until July, June or July of 2020, that the state of New Hampshire was actually opened up and our schools were allowed to continue with behind the wheel driving.
so trying to find a driver education school at that time frame probably was a little bit difficult.
I don't know where they were geographically in the state of New Hampshire, but typically in the state of New Hampshire, there are a number of schools.
We have about 75 driver education schools in the state of New Hampshire.
And to not be able to find one, especially at this time now, maybe back then it was a problem, but typically it is not a problem to find anybody.
Thank you so much for that.
You're welcome, ma'am.
I see before you go, Representative Hill, we've been beating up on Mr.
DuPont pretty good.
And while we've been doing it, I see three other hands raised, two of them from the Department of Safety.
I don't know if you want to ask him specifically or do you think you might get it from somebody else?
I'll hold on for the next person.
Thank you, sir.
And I think Mr.
DuPont thinks you're listening.
Like I said, if we're good, we'll move on.
Hold on, hold on.
Tupont, do you have any written testimony that you could send me in the committee?
Could you repeat that, please?
Do you have any written testimony that you could send to the committee?
I believe I can.
What I, my initial openings I do have typed down, but yes, I can.
That's the part that would be great.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yes, ma'am.
Captain Haynes.
Thank you.
sir um captain haynes um how about now is that better we can hear you now captain i'm sorry mr chairman mr chairman.
Chairman.
Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee, Captain Bill Haynes with the Office of Highway Safety, Department of Safety.
And I just wanted to share something with you to help in your decision process.
As you heard last year, there was a planned driver education assessment that was planned both last year and the year before.
And due to COVID last year, it was canceled.
I would submit to you that what that driver education assessment does through the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration, this takes a hard look at the curriculum of a program, and some of the things they talk about is one is program administration, the other is the education and training.
They talk a little bit about instructor qualifications, parental involvement, and then obviously how well everybody coordinates with the DMV.
So I would suggest before any laws were changed that perhaps you give that assessment an opportunity to go through.
And I do know that Director Balicki has applied for and been awarded a grant out of the Office of Highway Safety to conduct that assessment this year.
So I know that'll be bringing some pretty interesting information.
We might ask that they entertain an opportunity to look at our current program as to how we accept or don't accept out-of-state driving credentials for our youth and teen operators.
NHTSA does have a standardized recommendation for programs across the country.
And as Trooper DuPont said, they are vastly different everywhere.
However, there is a foundation for that.
And that's what they'll be looking at when they come to the state of New Hampshire.
And they will provide recommendations based on what they see, because many of us know one of the challenges we face is, are we going to go online with some of this?
So that's one of the reasons that I think we should wait and maybe entertain that as one collective group of information.
And the last thing I would offer is, from an Office of Highway Safety perspective, we're proponents of strengthening our graduated driver license.
But one thing we have to keep in mind is, in the instance of a person coming from another state who may or may not already have a driver license, it is our opportunity to make sure that our most trusted and valuable asset is protected and receives the proper training.
Unfortunately, once they've been licensed in another state, we do not have that opportunity.
And all we have is the choice of whether or not they've ever attended driver education.
So I think from my experience, I was a supervisor for licensing for many years prior to this.
And I would say to you that they are far and few between.
And I think the DMV has done a judicial job of trying to entertain them.
But again, I just highly encourage you to see what that assessment turns up.
I think you'll find it is a valuable tool for anything related to teen driving in the future.
Thank you.
Take any questions, Captain?
Yes, sir.
I would.
Representative Hill.
Just going to wait until the Department of Safety, if that's possible.
Okay.
Or DMV.
Fair enough.
Thank you, Captain.
Thank you.
And I apologize for jumping in at the end, but I'm hoping that I can answer some questions.
First of all, Trooper DuPont is fairly new to the position, and this was his first public hearing.
I think he did a phenomenal job answering all of your questions.
I do believe that hopefully the instance that the representative was speaking to was really an isolated instance that we have experienced.
Around that time, we did see some personnel changes within the driver education supervision.
So we had a little bit of a gap in staffing there as well.
But I do want to just point out a couple of things, and I promise I will be very brief.
I think the spirit of the law and the reciprocity is really to ensure that out-of-state drivers really meet the same standards as New Hampshire drivers and New Hampshire youth when it comes to driver education in the state.
Again, the legislature has spoken and determined that the driver education program that's contained in 263.19 is the standard that we want to follow for all of our youth drivers to ensure the safety on our roadways.
And the reciprocity really ensures that out-of-state drivers or out-of-state students really meet the same standard.
Truper DuPont and myself work really closely on all of our out-of-state transfers.
There's typically a move and so forth prior to the individual either completing or being able to get a license in the other state.
So we look at those very carefully to ensure that they meet New Hampshire standards and are in fact equivalent.
There are instances where they have to provide additional or complete additional either behind the wheel instruction or observation hours, very rarely classroom hours depending on the the content of the other out of state program.
But we really take a very close look and we really believe that we have quality driver education in the state and ensure that those transferring out of state also meet those requirements.
And with that, I thank you for your time.
Happy to answer any questions that you might have.
Thank you, Director.
Representative Hill.
Thank you, Chairman, and thank you, Director.
It would seem to me that there should be just a page on our website that indicates to a young person that may come to New Hampshire under these circumstances that would just indicate if you've lived in Ohio and you've taken driver ed, this is what you need to do here when you arrive in order to satisfy our requirements.
Is that not possible or does that already exist?
Thank you for the question, representative here.
That does exist.
I'd be happy to send you a link to that page on our website.
Thank you.
Follow up quickly.
Follow up.
So wouldn't that have solved the representative, the case that brought this bill to us?
It seemed that the person just couldn't get answers for weeks, I guess.
And it would seem that if they had the ability or just pointed to a link on the website, that it would show what requirements that person needed.
Is that not true?
Potentially it is, but I can tell you that yourself, myself, we're very familiar with New Hampshire laws, how to interpret them, how to read them as well.
It's not necessarily the case for all of our applicants.
They might go and look at our requirements, but sometimes might kind of feel lost in those requirements and not sure and not necessarily be able to interpret them to see how they apply to their situation.
So definitely, I think, a good start, but we find that many of them would prefer to speak to someone in person to really get any answers or answers to any of their questions and clarifications.
Thank you, Director.
Thank you.
Further questions?
Seeing none, thank you, Director.
Lucky.
Thank you, Director.
Thank you.
Further questions?
Seeing none, thank you, Director.
Thank you.
Dan Bennett updated.
Did he want to speak to this?
No, I accidentally gave him permission to talk.
I didn't mean to.
Okay.
All right, that's all I have signed up to speak.
I see no erase.
I'm not sure if I can speak to this.
I have signed up to speak.
I or no i accidentally gave him permission to talk i didn't mean to okay all right now that's all i have signed up to speak i see no more raised hands uh for the record we have one two three four five more four more members of the public in support and representative lynn uh also signed up in support.
With that, I'm going to close the public hearing on Coast Bill 175.
Give us just a couple of moments to reset, please.
All radio public hearing on House Bill 300, In relative to driver education.
Looking for Representative Lang.
I'll get an email a minute ago.
I think he's on his way.
I raised my hand, Mr.
Chairman.
I'm here.
Good afternoon, sir.
How are you?
Thank you very much.
Laura George.
Thank you, sir.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, committee members.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, for taking my testimony.
I give you House Bill 300 relative to driver's education, which seems to be a topic this afternoon.
This bill is a pretty straightforward bill.
It does basically one thing.
It allows parents the option of teaching their own children driver's education.
This is not an uncommon action in other states.
There are other states that allow parents to teach their children, both the classroom and behind the wheel training.
I would, as I listened to the other bill that was just heard, a bunch of things came to mind about the conversation around driver's education, how we've institutionalized it and made it so that, you know, we can't think of a time when we don't have it, which I think needs to be a changed mindset.
If COVID taught us anything, our mandates at the state level create significant impediment to our citizens in the state of New Hampshire, and driver's ed is no exception to that.
We saw that the governor had to issue executive order 18, which waived some of the requirements for driver's education, including six hours of observation time, and allowed parents to do that observation time.
We saw that the issue, I serve on the governor's reopening task force myself, and Bill Marsh wrote the guidance for the driver's education programs to reopen, and those guidances were issued in May and the governor immediately acted upon them and allowed for the terms and conditions that allowed the driver's education to operate in a safe and effective manner during this COVID.
But again, many parents were interrupted.
And I don't know how many phone calls I took on the task force relative to this driver's education mandate and the fact that they wanted to teach their own kid and let them go take the test.
And we were stuck with driver's schools, as you heard from the previous, were closed.
They were unavailable.
Some were, even though they were allowed to open, chose not to open.
And geographically, that could be an issue, especially when you look up north in in our northern community there's not very many driver's education opportunities up there I mean I was looking at one up in Lancaster and their next two classes are completely full so if you're a student who wants to get get your driver's license you have to wait till April or May now before you would get into a class to take your take your driver's education education and then do your work.
Just as a backup to remind people what are the requirements for driver's education is that under the instruction side for driver's education, you have to have 30 hours of classroom instruction from a certified driver's education instructor, 10 hours of practice time in driving, six hours of observation time of driving, and that's all with an instructor.
But there's 40 hours of practice time in driving, six hours of observation time of driving.
That's all with an instructor.
But there's 40 hours of additional driving that are done with the parents.
So over 80% or 80% of the driving is actually done with the parents already.
And I was, again, listening to that other conversation.
I found it kind of amusing considering when I was getting my driver's license, I was living in Alaska, and Alaska doesn't have a driving education requirement.
But the overriding factor I heard in that last conversation, we're talking about how this impacts New Hampshire citizens and the ability to go.
And we're talking about inexperienced drivers and how our youngest citizens who just get their licenses are the ones most apt to be in an accident or have issues.
We heard about issues and the troopers talking about driving on the first day of a snowstorm when winter rolls around.
And I was a police officer.
I spent years in uniform, over a decade in a police uniform.
And I can tell you, that's an absolute true statement.
We used to almost want to call in sick when we heard there was going to be a snowstorm coming up.
Because that first day of driving, every citizen's forgotten how to drive in the snow.
And you're doing nothing but pulling cars out of ditches all day long.
And just taking traffic accident reports, which is just, you know, not very fun.
So I get it.
But all those people have had driver's education, right.
So you're talking about the inexperienced drivers that are off the road.
They've already been through.
We have a mandate.
They've already been on the road.
So either our driver's education isn't functioning or it's not tied to safe driving.
There has to be a correlation there.
And apparently all the other conversation we just had was the fact that the driver's education, these people have already been, we have a mandate that's been around for over 20 years, if not longer.
And yet everybody under the age of 40 has been through and is still running off the road in the first day of a snow storm.
So I'm not sure there's correlation there.
But the last thing I'd say is that by removing the requirement of a driver's education does not mean you're putting unsafe drivers on the road.
We still have a check and balance system in place.
That check and balance is the Department of Motor Vehicle does a written exam to make sure they understand the basic rules of the road as it relates to the laws of New Hampshire.
And that they know what they're allowed to do and not allowed to do.
And then that's followed up by a practical exam by a highway safety officer who takes that new licensed driver and takes them out on the road.
I can't imagine either DMV or the highway safety officer allowing an unfit driver on the road.
Regardless of how they learn to become fit, they're not going to let that unfit driver on the road.
So there is a check and balance against this system.
And some people are concerned, do we take away driver's education, we're going to have just crazy drivers on the road.
But the reality is that that's not true.
Everybody takes the same exam, whether you've been to the driver's education program, or in my case, if your parents are teaching it.
I will tell you, I spoke to a high school, a couple of superintendents about this bill.
And the superintendents of the schools are telling me that this creates an imbalance in their school because you have some have and have nots.
I'm not sure if the committee is aware, but the cost of a driver's education program is 600 and sometimes over $700.
Again, some of the research I did, we have in the state driver's education programs that cost more than $750 to take.
And that's...
hundred and sometimes over seven hundred dollars again some of the research i did we have in the state um driver's education programs that cost more than 750 to take and that creates a huge impediment to lower income people or even even low to middle class income people um that that that huge burden to overcome to allow their their child to be able to get a driver's license so they can get a job and be productive and go to work is huge and only further creates a disparity between the income classes.
A person who's a high income at work doesn't care about $700.
They can pay the $750 for their child to go get it.
But a person who is struggling paycheck to paycheck and that cost of $700 additional cost that's mandated by the state for their 16-year- old to go get their driver's license can be a huge obstacle.
And there is no easy way out of it.
And so I think this is a socioeconomic problem in our society.
I think this creates a bigger gap in the have and have nots and creates problems in high schools.
I will tell you that the superintendents I spoke to said that if this bill passed, they would consider offering the book side of this class in their schools as an elective because they'd be allowed to do it.
It doesn't have to be a certified driver's education program.
They could offer the book learning piece, order the materials from the driver's book from the Department of Motor Vehicle and offer on a quarterly basis the book learning so the parents can focus on the practical learning.
But none of this can happen unless this bill passes and allows it to happen.
I'm happy to take questions from the committee, but again, I think this restores parental rights.
I learned to drive by my parents.
I imagine many committee members here learned to drive with their parents.
Some of us learned to drive on equipment that wasn't even a car.
It was a tractor or a piece of construction equipment.
So again, there are more ways to learn than just going to a classroom.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you.
I see a couple of hands up.
Representative Hill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And thank you, Representative, for bringing the bill forward.
Do you see a situation where a student may not be able to afford the driver ed cost and simply just waits until they turn 18 and takes the exam without ever having driver ed?
And wouldn't that be a detriment to society having never taken driver ed prior to taking the exam?
Thank you, Representative Hill for your question.
And that's exactly true.
Somehow there's a magical thing that happens when you're 17 years, 364 days, you can't have a license.
But that very next day, all of a sudden you can walk in, take the written exam, take the practical exam, and you can get a license.
I think that is a disservice.
I think that everybody can be served by allowing this bill to move forward.
Thank you.
Representative Thank you Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you.
Representative Gagnon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative Lange, for my question.
I really don't know if it's too late, but I'm looking at your analysis, and it's, you know, responsible adults, et cetera, provides instruction behind All right.
And you also said that the parents have to do 40 hours of extra driving to hold their children's skills.
Would proof needed or required to show that they had covered the prior requirements that a driver didn't spoke with would do for it.
I'm sorry, Mr.
Chairman, can you restate the question?
He's really, the representative was really muffled and I didn't follow the question.
Yeah, he's kind of a long ways away from you.
Hang on for a minute.
Try again, Larry.
I'm going to go over here.
Off camera, can you hear me?
I can hear you perfectly now, sir.
I'm next to a mic instead of being 15 feet away.
Thank you for taking my question again and your patience.
I'm looking at the analysis and I listened to your testimony.
The classroom instruction behind the wheel training.
I see that the parents also have to do 40 hours of driving with their children.
Would proof be required or needed to show that what they would probably learn in the driver's ed class that probably would not be covered?
Would the state need to have proof that that part of the instruction was covered?
So thank you, Representative, for that question.
And again, if you read the last line of the bill in Section 5, It says that the parent uh has has provided classroom instruction behind the wheel training as equivalent to the approved driver education course so again based on the the driver's education course is outlined in the department of safety um rules and regulations so you know what what sections and what components and how much time you have to spend on each topic and the parents would have to do that same same stuff just not at a driver's education school the parents would have to follow the same that same uh department of safety regulation please okay but would they have to send in written uh written proof that what they had that fulfilled all those prior requirements.
They would have to sign an affidavit that they met the conditions now.
Thank you.
Representative Eric.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Representative Lange, for bringing this bill forward.
I have to say that we homeschooled our three kids.
My husband taught our kids how to drive.
So this is a very welcome bill in my eyes.
I'm just interested to know, do you know how many states allow parental instruction in this manner?
I know Connecticut does.
So I don't have the exact number.
number I know when I did this this is a retread bill I've done it I had this bill before and the last time I did the research there were eight states in in the United States that allowed for parents to do their teach their children how to drive.
Okay thank you very much I appreciate this.
See no further questions.
Thank you, Representative.
Mr.
Chair, I can just reiterate one last thing.
I just, again, just want to remind everybody, the written exam and the practical exam is the proof in the pudding.
So DMV always has the say on who gets a license and who doesn't.
And those two tests are what is supposed to delineate between a good driver and a bad driver.
Thank you, sir.
Chair recognizes the chair.
Cameron, the National Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
The New Hampshire Drivers Education Teachers Association opposes House Bill 300.
The same bill has been presented twice already.
In 2018, the committee voted 16 to 3 to find the bill inexpedient to legislate, and in 2019, the vote was 15 to 2 for the same reasons that still exist today.
Driver education is only required for 16 and 17-year-old students who want a license before they turn 18.
It is but one piece of a system designed to produce safe and competent young drivers that includes driver education, 40 hours of parent supervised practice, and a graduated driver license system designed to build privileges over a period of time.
A parent, guardian, or responsible adult that can provide classroom instruction and behind-the-wheel training that is equivalent to an approved driver education course, as outlined in the bill, needs to meet the requirements of a driver education instructor.
That would require the same eight college courses and workshops, 300 hours of student teaching, knowledge and skills tests, background checks, a clean driving record, and oversight provided by the Department of Motor Vehicles.
Anything less would not meet the equivalent standard as laid out in this bill.
This bill has the potential to Thank you.
driving record and oversight provided by the Department of Motor Vehicles.
Anything less would not meet the equivalent standard as laid out in this bill.
This bill has the potential to cost the state money.
I'm sure the DMV will speak to the fiscal impact on their department, and I can imagine it could be expensive as it will create more traffic through their offices.
There are more than 60 driver education schools in the state, all small businesses.
Aside from the concerns of safety, this will put many of those schools out of business, resulting in fewer options for students who opt to keep a professional in the process.
This bill has the potential to cost the public money as well.
The insurance discount for taking a driver ed course ranges from 5 to 20 percent, depending on the company, and lasts until a student turns 21, as long as they keep their driving record clean.
I'm told by a colleague who is a former insurance professional that a state with positions on laws that have potential to weaken public safety has a negative impact effect on insurance rates.
Most parents haven't taken driver education courses for decades and their team going through a program is an opportunity for the entire family to tighten up their skills and learn current laws and practices as they relate to safety.
I appreciate my students reteaching their folks and they of course love that.
The COVID-19 pandemic has the potential to change the face of driver ed forever in this state.
Instructors like teachers everywhere have been forced to reinvent classes to be delivered in a remote format.
To be clear, driver ed is not currently an online class.
It is a remote class.
Teachers and students can see each other and communicate as if they were still in a classroom.
As the worldwide emergency eventually passes, many industries, including driver education, will have an opportunity to explore how changes can be made that will improve the delivery and access of classes in ways we never thought possible.
New Hampshire DITA will be working to gather information from many instructors in the state to identify the advantages and challenges.
That knowledge has the potential to bring meaningful change to the system while maintaining public safety.
Thank you for the opportunity to speak today.
I would be happy to entertain questions.
Thank you.
And just for the record, I tried stopping you at the beginning.
Can you just state your name for the clerk for the record?
I'm so sorry.
Sharon Cameron, New Hampshire Drivers Education Teachers Association.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you again.
The chair recognizes Jana El-Sayed.
Sorry, Mr.
Chair, who did you say?
J-A-N-A, Jaina El-Sayed.
EL-SAYED.
I don't see her on.
Yeah, I don't see her either.
If she's there, could she raise her hand?
Okay, I'm going to check it now.
We'll return.
Chair recognizes.
Adrian Soti.
S-O-T-I.
Just promoted her.
What's that?
I just promoted.
Just from over there.
Thank you.
You're still muted.
There you go.
Okay.
Works now.
Hello.
So my name is Adrian Soti.
as a member of the public, a mother to three kids, and a wife of Representative Julius Soti of Winham, who's also in favor, I'm here to testify in support of House Bill 300.
Granite State Driving School charged $600 for their drivers at program two years ago when my daughter completed it in person at Wyndham High School.
Currently, there is an emergency executive order due to COVID that wisely allows the classroom instruction of the driver's ed to be completed fully online.
The previous speaker said it's remote, not online.
I think they both have benefits and disadvantages.
Being online, the benefit of it is you could you could pause and rewind and listen again if you didn't catch something.
So the driver's ed is now fully remote and rather than only allowing 15 hours out of the 30 to be online, you would think that since there's no building involved, the fee for the course would be decreased.
But instead of getting a discount, it's going to cost $100 more to have my 16-year-old son complete the online Granite State course.
I'm here to tell you that I feel fully competent myself to teach this course with the help of the freely available driver's manual and the $20 supplemental textbook used by Granite State Driving School.
There are a multitude of instructional videos available on YouTube, as well as an interactive online course offered through AAA that's equivalent to 25 hours of in-class instruction for only $25.
Now, in addition, family schedules are an important factor.
I remember how difficult it was to find a program that worked with our schedule two years ago, and I'm facing the same difficulty right now.
The class we chose was already filled by the time the school received our application, even though their website still shows it's fully open and available.
The one that is still open doesn't work with our schedule.
Now we have to wait for the next time they offer the course.
Sometimes this means that a student has to wait months to find a course that fits into their schedule, even though they could begin studying immediately.
This, of course, doesn't stop them from practicing driving with their parents who can start teaching the rules found in your driver's manual right away instead of waiting for the school to do it.
New Hampshire requires that those under 18 years of age drive 10 hours with an instructor.
However, it doesn't make those 10 hours a prerequisite to starting practicing with a parent.
This way, students may have already completed the 40 hours of driving practice required for applying for a license.
Does it really make a difference whether they get an additional 10 hours through an instructor or through another adult with a license?
And as it was said earlier, the proof is in the test.
A young person can take a written and practical test at the DMV at the age of 18 without any of the requirements spelled out in RSA 26319.
A few months before their 18th birthday, however, they are burdened with an expensive course, even if they have studied and drove under the guidance of their parents for more than the required time.
If the DMV test is reliable, regardless of who prepared the young motorist, passing the written test and the driving test will serve as proof that preparation was satisfactory.
Therefore, I strongly recommend that this committee adopt this bill and acknowledge the many hours of preparation that parents can provide as an alternative to the approved driver's ed program.
Thank you very much.
Any questions of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you again.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes Dan Goodman from the AAA and opposition to the bill.
Hello, can you hear me okay?
You can.
Good afternoon, sir.
Thank you, Chairman.
Sorry about that.
When I unmuted it, I tried to restart.
So, Chairman Walsh and committee members, thank you very much for giving me the opportunity.
For the record, my name is Dan Goodman.
I'm a public affairs manager for AAA Northern New England.
And I'm speaking in opposition to HB 300.
I submitted some written testimony, so I'll be really brief.
AAA has done a lot of research around teen drivers, and we know that they're the most vulnerable drivers, and as someone said earlier, I like that they're our most valuable resources, and we know teen drivers are three times as likely as adults to be involved in a deadly crash, and we know there was research done a few years ago at the Texas Transportation Institute that looked at this very issue.
They completed a comparative evaluation of parent-taught driver education versus the traditional instructor-based driver education program.
The research determined that Texas teenagers taught to drive by someone other than a professional driving instructor are more likely to be convicted of driving violations, including speeding, and more likely to be involved in serious crashes.
They also found that after the GDL license restrictions, like night and passenger restrictions that were talked about earlier, were lifted, parent-taught drivers are nearly three times more likely to be involved in a fatal crash than those that were taught by professional driving instructors.
I do agree.
I do really agree that parents and guardians play a really crucial role in the learning to drive process, but they should not be considered a substitute for the professional in-car instruction.
So that's all I have to say, and I really appreciate the opportunity to speak, and I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Any questions?
Never mind, Representative Hill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and thank you for taking my question.
I understand the analysis that was done on parent-directed instruction versus a professional company instruction.
But in New Hampshire, where a student just needs to wait till age 18 and then they can have no instruction, is it not better for there to be some parental instruction rather than no instruction?
Thank you very much, Representative, for that question.
I don't know if I can answer that completely, but I'll try to answer it in a couple of different ways.
I actually think it's problematic that individuals can wait until they're 18 and then just get their license.
I think we should have some sort of evaluation of their driving ability before they can just get their driver's license.
And I actually forgot what I was going to say on the second part of this.
Happens to us all the time.
Sorry about that.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
That is the last one I have signed up.
Let me check for raised hands if anybody else wishes to speak on this.
Yeah, there's two in the queue.
What's that?
There's two people in the queue, Richard Dupont and Gail Hoyt.
Okay.
Mr.
Dupont.
Sorry about the delay.
The system, it causes us to, there's a slight delay and then you have to unmute yourself.
So I apologize for the delay.
It's not you.
We've been dealing with it all day.
I know you are, but I feel like I need to apologize.
You threw the bags into my eyes through the monitor, I'm sure.
No comment.
Just kidding.
So, again, thank you for allowing me to speak with you today.
And I've already currently previously introduced myself, so I'm just going to go into it.
I speak today in opposition to House Bill 300.
it appears to speak to a change in the language of RSA 263-14, which is the original youth licenses, operators licenses, and RSA 263-19, which is driver's education.
And again, as I spoke earlier, in the past, the state of New Hampshire, the state legislature spoke to the quality of our state's program that is currently in place and what that program should look like.
And it can be found again in RSA 263.19 and also in RSA 21-P.14, which speaks to the development of rules governing driver's education, specifically to the Department of Safety Administrative Rule 3100 series and to RSA 26344, which is motor vehicle driver schools, as it relates to the driver's education course, the schools and the qualifications of those instructors.
The state legislature, again, with all the Department of Education, the Department of Drivers Education Association, the Division of Motor Vehicles, the state legislature put together a really quality program to have certified instructors teach our young drivers how to properly and safely operate a motor vehicle upon the roadways of New Hampshire.
This same program has been successful for many years.
It is understood that most parents are not professional instructors and are not seemingly attempting to become professional instructors.
However, the process to become a professional instructor is important and that the level of training they initially receive is college level and the level of training that they are expected to maintain to maintain their certifications is also very important.
It's a distinction between a regular person and a certified professional instructor.
Each school and each instructor is held to a standard above a normal person in the driver education program they teach to our young drivers is a quality program that our state has again benefited for many years.
The language suggested to be added to RSA 26319 would have an overwhelming consequence on the driver education office and subsequently to the state as a whole.
To effectively review each waiver would take hours and conceivably months to verify that the driver's education program envisioned by our state legislature was actually taught and in what manner it was actually taught.
The review would significantly reduce the time now used to monitor the certified driving schools and certified instructors for compliance with the laws and rules governing driver's education.
The answer of questions through phone calls from New Hampshire residents is also part of our function and we take calls and answer questions from persons from other states who wish to transfer here and transfer the driver's education program from another state.
In reality, each waiver would have been taught by a different parent or guardian or, as the language is written, a responsible adult.
Now, I don't, addressing that, potentially a young adult could be an 18-year-old who is deemed responsible.
And I have to wonder about how much driving experience and skills that that person would have.
Every person in New Hampshire has different driving and teaching abilities, and there's no way to really ensure that the driver education program intended to be taught to our young drivers was taught correctly and in keeping with the program set forth by our legislature.
An example of this, you can draft your own number, but I'm going to use 10,000 different people could conceivably be teaching how to operate a motor vehicle 10,000 different ways.
Some could be fathers, mothers, grandparents, aunts and uncles, and in some circumstances, maybe even a sibling as a guardian at a very young age.
All of these people will have different ages, different skill sets, and different driving and life experience.
Somebody said something about parents are, you know, are quite capable, and I agree that the parents are very capable of raising their children, But driver's education is an important aspect of driving in our communities.
An example from my own experience is, and I think we all can relate, you have the parents or potential parents that will drive down the highway at the speed limit.
Then you have the parents that, oh, it's okay to do five over.
Then you have the parents that are okay to do 10 over.
I mean, this just goes on and on, right?
So everybody has a different threshold and view of what is proper and what is accepted and which is actually the legal law of driving down a road.
Not to mention, people have different driving skills and different driving conditions.
Driver's education, the schools and the instructors keep up with the times, and they also teach the safety features of all the vehicles that are out there, and that's ever-changing.
The technology technology is ever changing.
So to compare a driver's education program from the past isn't fair and isn't doing justice because technology is changing.
There are different features and these schools and these instructors are keeping up with that pace and they're actually able to address the blind spots, able to address different safety features of the vehicles.
The 80%, the comment of 80% of the driving time for a young adult is with the parents, okay?
But the 40 hours is designated to augment what they've already been taught, not to teach them driver's education all over again.
That's just to provide additional driving to the young adult.
We want them to be safe before they actually go out on their own on our roadways.
Florida, for example, requires that you drive for one year with a licensed adult before you can even get your license.
So again, each state is different.
The checks and balances regarding, you know, understanding that test at the DMV, the tests at the DMV are the basic rules.
That's the comment.
But that's only the basics.
Everyone takes the same exam.
Yes, they do.
But I would argue that instruction other than standardized training is important.
And that test that's being taken at the DMV is only a snapshot of your actual driving experience.
It's a very short amount of time.
It's not the full 100% gauge of what your driving ability actually is.
I can talk to you about my father-in-law now who's deceased, but we, you know, he was elderly and he had a whole different driving skill.
He was perfect when he took his driving test.
but then after that, he was a mess on the road.
Sorry to keep going.
No problem.
In closing, the laws and rules as they are at this time allow for a quality driver education program to be delivered to our young drivers by training certified instructors which ultimately keeps our road safe.
Thank you and I will take any questions at this time.
Thank you.
A couple of questions.
Representative Thank you Mr.
Chairman I'll be very quick.
TrooperPont, I'm a little concerned about the vagueness here of how the student would go with their guardian to prove that they'd had the training.
Do you have any initial thoughts on what they would have to provide to be able to prove equivalent training?
What form that could take?
Right now, as it's written, it's a waiver from the parent or an affidavit saying that they provided the program the way it was intended by our legislature.
But other than providing the curriculum that you taught your young adult and, you know, check marks of, oh, yes, I did this, I did this, I did this.
I don't know how else they would be able to prove it unless they downloaded an approved program and then went through that checklist.
But how would you prove that that actually occurred?
I don't know.
I mean, I guess there is an incentive, and you hate to say this, but for parents to just get through the program, the process, like the parents that would drive more than 10 miles an hour over the speed limit, just because they want to have their son or daughter drive themselves to soccer practice.
There's no way to fact check it.
And, yeah, there's just no oversight on it.
And how would you know that the program, these drivers are safe?
At least right now with the driving education schools, they are mandated and there's oversight on them.
And they know that they need to teach everything in the proper way and manner as it was intended.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I see another question, Senator Valhara.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Trooper DuPont.
I just had one quick question.
Don't we already have a law on the book saying that if you're learning to drive, the person, the adult driving with you has to be over at least the age of 25?
Yes.
Okay, so it couldn't be an 18-year-old going with them.
I just wanted to make sure that part was...
Well, that is a good point, but that does not say that in this bill.
Okay, any more questions?
Trooper DuPont.
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Who is the representative of the Herald?
We have somebody in the queue still.
Thank you.
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Who is the representative of the Herald?
We have somebody in the queue still.
We have Director Bileski.
Sorry.
I see a D.
Oh.
She put her hand down as I was.
Put her hand down.
I'm still here.
Can you hear me?
Okay.
Chair recognizes Gail Hall.
Hall, you're going to make this.
It's the director that is on.
Gail put her hand down as I was getting ready to put her on the director blackie i apologize thank you mr chairman um thank you again for giving me some time for the record elizabeth bielakki director of motor vehicles um i just want to add a few things to trooper dupont's testimony um and specifically speaking to fiscal impact and i think the committee really has a good gauge on on some of our concerns on this as well.
The way I interpret it, we really do have the responsibility to ensure the equivalency of the course that's being taught by a parent or responsible adult.
The way I would look at it is that we need to ensure that we review every single waiver that's submitted to us for a waiver of driver education and ensure that those standards have been met.
As Trooper DuPont has mentioned, we do have a really strict oversight of driver education schools right now, which means that they are regularly audited to ensure that they remain compliant with our regulation, that they maintain classroom standards and curriculum standards as well.
If we were to apply the similar standards to these waivers, we really would need to review each one of those submitted to us to ensure that that was met, unless the legislature intends this to be a self-certification or some kind of an affidavit, in which case I think the law would need to be adjusted.
There was a question regarding the 25-year-old.
Again, as Tupper Dupont stated, this law does not require someone to be over the age of 25 in order to teach this class as well.
So I think that would need to be clarified as well.
And again, I think we have a great program in the state.
In addition to just teaching classroom behind the wheel observation, the different instructors introduce different type of visual aids and other aids in addition to the curriculum that's currently required to ensure that the students really receive quality education.
I think the prior speaker spoke to the certification of the teachers and the classroom education, the driver education schools as well.
So I'll leave it at that.
From a fiscal impact perspective, I think I would require additional personnel in order to really meet that standard of reviewing the equivalency of those parent taught classes.
We have about 13,000 or so students that go through driver education each year.
And, you know, take a percentage, 50% of those being parent-taught, that is a lot of equivalent waivers that we would have to review.
With that, I will close my testimony and answer any questions that you might have.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you, Director.
Thank you.
Okay.
I see nobody else signed up.
Is there anybody else in the queue?
Uh-oh.
I see hands.
Gail raised her hand again, so I just promoted her.
You say that one.
Gail Holt.
She just raised her hand again, so I promoted her.
You say that one more time.
Gail Holt.
She just raised her hand again, so I promote her now.
There we go.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you now.
Good afternoon.
Thank you very much.
So my name is Gay Holt.
I have taught driver education in the state of New Hampshire for 35 years.
And I just kind of wanted to weigh in on things because I've left a lot of changes over time.
I'll make a quick way to run a lot of time on this committee.
So as Sharon Cameron had explained, that's the head of the association currently for driver's ed, you have a discount on insurance, which is gained from having taken driver's ed for the students.
I know the fiscal impact was one of...
Association currently for driver's ed.
You have a discount on insurance, which is gained from having taken driver's ed for the students.
I know the fiscal impact was one of Representative Lang's concerns, which I totally get.
Unfortunately, as everybody is seeing in their own life, there is an amount of money and percentages every year going up.
My insurance for my commercial driver's ed this year just went up substantially.
So I understand concerns on the money end.
As far as the pandemic, it's not only New Hampshire, we are currently doing recertification time right now as driving instructors.
We have to do 51 additional hours every three years.
And in fact, Sharon Cameron, who spoke earlier, and myself are going to be logging on in just over an hour for another four-hour seminar towards that goal.
One of the things that we listened to last night was in reference to the pandemic has basically just taken this across the whole United States.
This is not prevalent to just New Hampshire currently.
Everything has kind of gone sideways, as we all know, with our stay-at-home orders.
And I'm currently doing classroom remotely on Zoom.
The one thing I am learning is always to be professional, which I always am, but now I'm learning there are parents sitting to the side off screen listening to driver's ed, which you know what I'm really happy about because I am teaching not only the student, but every time I'm hearing the parents saying, I didn't know that.
I didn't know that.
I learned this.
I learned that.
And I've done this long enough that I've had multiple children in the same family.
And as I'm told by those parents, every time one of their students takes driver's ed with me, they're learning more and new things.
So as far as staying up on technology, I'm actually teaching in a 2018 Volkswagen Tiguan.
My kids are loving it.
It has all kinds of technology on it.
But at the same time, if I know the car they're driving in doesn't have a backup camera, I shut it off.
I tell them don't rely on those blind spot detectors.
So there are many things that I've learned over the years that I keep evolving.
As my husband says, every day is a learning day.
And one of the things often that we're seeing, and I see this even this morning with a student, is while I appreciate the parents being right there with us doing the backup of the 40 hours, which is meant to reinforce what we're doing on the roads.
I've also learned that they've watched their parents for 16 years.
And often I am trying to rectify bad habits that have come about and trying to explain to kids why you stop behind stop lines for three seconds, why you scan an intersection, you know, why you look over your shoulder, why you watch your back end.
And I'm not going to be here to teach you driver's ed because I've done it long enough.
I could probably do it for hours.
I think, if anything, perhaps you should keep the requirement for the 16 and 17 year olds as it stands.
one representative did bring forward the thought that well what if at 18 they're just able to I believe it was keep the requirement for the 16 and 17 year olds as it stands.
One representative did bring forward the thought that, well, what if at 18, they're just able to, I believe it was Representative Hill.
And you're right, Representative Hill, you know, maybe there should be education for everybody.
But maybe at that point, it becomes requirement on your end, that anyone 18 and above is required to do some kind of program.
The driver's manual is totally separate in the learning process from what I'm doing in my program, just so that that's understood.
As I tell students, the program is the theory of driving, the driver's manual are the laws of our state.
And last but not least, I'd just like to close with explaining Trooper Haynes gave testimony in the prior committee meeting that you just had in far as the bill that went before this.
And as he explained, due to the pandemic, they were in the process of reevaluating the driver ed program here in New Hampshire on a national level.
And he was asking that if we could hold off and wait, I think that would be a wonderful suggestion.
And on that, I will close.
And if anyone has questions, happy to answer them.
Thank you very much.
Any questions from the committee?
Thank you.
Thank you again.
Okay.
Representative O'Hara, is there anybody up?
I see no hands raised on my screen yeah representative tom plo jay i think or no not is that pomper tom prochar sorry that was plojay is that oh okay uh chair recognizes recognizes tom pres.
Good morning, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
Thank you for taking my testimony.
I'll be very brief.
I just wanted to identify a couple of things.
Gay Holt had mentioned the NITS assessment.
I was going to bring that up and ask the committee what they hold off on making any dramatic changes to the driver's ed program until we see the results from that assessment.
I also heard a number of concerns around access to driver education.
And as Representative Lang had mentioned, the governor issued emergency order number 18 to allow for the classroom portion of driver education to be conducted remotely.
And I wanted to notify the committee that the Senate has recently introduced Senate Bill 155, which would put that emergency order into effect through January 31st, 2022.
And also in regards to access, in 2019, the legislature in this committee approved Senate Bill 60, which allowed for 15 hours of the classroom instruction to be conducted online, which I believe we are currently in the process of stakeholders of meeting with the director on developing those rules.
So I think greater access will be forthcoming.
And with that, I'll close my testimony, but just want to make the committee aware of some of those steps that have been taken in recent years.
you mr presall any questions from the committee seeing none thank you again i see no more hands up all right um not including the people that spoke originally signed in 33 and support 10 opposed to house bill 300 again it doesn include the people that have raised their hand after the fact.
So with that, I'm going to close the public hearing on House Bill 300.
Okay.
Before we get into the next one, we are a half an hour late.
I'll have to take some of the blame for that.
But I'm also going to blame the fact that not everybody gets up and signs up prior to when we start these hearings.
So when I only see three or four people signed up, I don't bother putting time constraints on anybody because I don't think I need to.
And then before I know it, there's 10 more people that are signed up on the screen, and I don't think it's fair that I start time constraints when the people before them didn't happen.
That's why I didn't do it this time.
It's never going to happen again, trust me.
We have time constraints on the next one, right out of the gate.
We have a slew of people that are signed up for it.
This is not favoritism on any bill, but again, with the system and not knowing who is actually signed up ahead of time, not even having an idea of who's going to be makes it very difficult.
That being said, before we get into House Bill 251, I don't know what you need to put on the screen to let everybody aware that we're not going anywhere.
This one will be heard just a little bit late.
That being said, I'll see you all at five past three.
at least.
Thank you.
Okay.
Before I open this up, like I said at the end of the previous hearing, it's very hard to gauge, and I want to be fair to everybody so I'm going to start with a time limit.
Right now I've got seven people signed up, that signed up in advance.
The way the trend is going, I have no reason to believe it won't be 14 by the time we're at the end of it.
Again, I do not like doing time restraints after the fact.
I think it's fair if we start off that way.
It's got nothing to do with the bill, just the time of the day.
So our vice chair has been generous enough to decide we're going to do four minutes, and he'll be watching the clock.
So with that, I'm going to open up the public hearing on House Bill 251, an act requiring children under the age of two years to be strained in a motor vehicle.
Representative Fenton.
I'm here.
Can you hear me?
You can.
Good afternoon, sir.
Good afternoon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair and ladies and gentlemen of the committee.
My name is Rep.
Donovan Fenton.
For the record, I represent Keene.
I'm here today to talk to you about HB 251, which would be requiring children under the age of two to be restrained in a rear-facing car seat.
I'm going to keep this very short because we have a lot of speakers on this bill, and I ask if you have any pointed questions that you save them for the experts speaking next.
This bill is the same as last year that passed the House and got lost in the COVID mess.
The only difference is we have an amendment regarding the manufacturer laws that will help clear up any confusion that we had last year.
So essentially this bill would add protection for our children.
The American Academy of Pediatrics has expanded their car seat recommendations to keep children rear-facing for as long as possible.
They did this because it'll help save lives.
Every month that a child rides rear-facing gives them more time for the head and neck to fully develop.
A rear-facing car seat cradles a child's entire body, and it only takes one-fourth inch of a stretch for a child's spinal cord to rupture.
Using the correct car seat can decrease death or serious injury by 70%.
Currently, there is no language to protect infants.
My wife and I have a two-and-a-half-year-old that's still rear-facing, as well as a newborn.
I'm sure some of you parents know I couldn't believe how fragile and small a new child is.
And I can't fathom, nor do I want to, what would happen to them in a serious car crash.
So I thank you for your time.
And with that, I'll take any questions or, yeah.
Thank you, Representative.
And I was remiss.
Congratulations, by the way.
Thank you.
That's why I'm not on video, because I have very big bags under my eyes at the moment.
Any questions for Representative Fenton from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes, Dan Goodman from, no, yeah, looks like this was signed up incorrectly.
Anyway, Dan Goodman, chair recognizes.
Are you there, sir?
Says you're an elected official representing yourself.
So I don't believe that to be the case.
Yeah, that's not the case.
Can you hear me okay?
I can.
It's nice to be back.
Yeah.
And to clarify for the record, it's Dan Goodman, not representative, public affairs manager for AAA Northern New England.
And I'm speaking in support of the bill.
And know the company the committee is running behind so I'll be really really brief as representative Fenton said this bill protects the most vulnerable and the youngest more vehicle passengers beside the academy of pediatricians the national traffic safety administration all agree that children should ride rear-facing as long as possible and at least until two years of age or until they reach the weight or height limits of manufacturer of the seat.
There are a lot, a lot of studies out there that show that this will keep children much safer and more secure.
Happy to share any of them.
A University of Virginia study found that children were 75% less likely to suffer severe or fatal injuries in a crash if they were rear-facing.
Rear-facing seats are designed to support the children's fragile body.
I included in my testimony a link to a video simulation of an 18-month-old child in a rear-facing versus a forward-facing safety seat that was made by the Children's Hospital of Philadelphia Research Institute.
I really encourage you to watch it.
I have a 19-month-old daughter and a pregnant wife, and it's very, very shocking.
Under the existing RSA, there's no specific language to guide parents and caregivers on the appropriate type of child restraint used at various stages of development.
This legislation before you today will help close that gap in child pastor safety in New Hampshire's law.
So with that, I'll close my testimony.
Thank you for the time and consideration.
I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you for testimony, Mr.
Goodman.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes Cindy Tuttle representing Concord hospital.
Good afternoon, commissioner.
Is it possible to do video sharing?
Can you do that?
I'm going to go ahead and do that.
Good afternoon, Commissioner.
Is it possible to do video sharing?
Can you pull up my video?
If she clicks share screen, she can do it.
You did?
You just need to click share screen.
All right.
Oh, wait, like your video or your screen?
My screen, please.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay, great.
Thank you very much.
Hi, I'm Cindy Tuttle.
I am a nurse educator and nursing supervisor at Concord Hospital, representing Concord Hospital, and a child pastor safety instructor.
So thank you for the opportunity to testify for this bill.
I feel strongly encouraged by this bill simply because I see the day-to-day injury that occur with children.
In this seat here, I have a rear-facing infant seat, and this would be a forward-facing seat.
So facing you would be the front of the car.
And if that frontal crash would occur, which is about 70% of all crashes occur occur, the rear-facing infant seat would come toward you first and then up toward the back of the seat and then back down.
This child in this seat would be properly restrained and within the seat itself, protecting the head, the neck, and the spinal cord.
Unlike our child who would be rear-facing, forward facing seat would be facing the front of the vehicle and this child would be coming forward and you can see the potential for the stretching of the head and neck which Representative Fenton has already described and the potential for spinal cord injury with children that are forward facing.
So markedly different in our children and our one to two year old age group is certainly at risk if this bill is not passed.
So I do ask you for your support of this.
I would be glad to entertain any questions.
Question?
Recognizes?
Mr.
Chairman, we cannot hear you.
You can't hear me either?
Now we can.
It was some background noise from Cindy's computer.
Yeah, I don't know what's going on.
I just had something pop up on my screen a minute ago, too.
I couldn't get rid of that.
We're back to normal now.
The chair recognizes Tom Leach.
In support the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, representatives for hearing discussion on this very important bill today.
I just want to make sure, can you hear me?
I can.
If you can just state your name and who you represent.
Yes, my name is Tom Leach.
I work for Chad Children's Hospital at Dartmouth-Hitchcock.
I am the New Hampshire State Child Passenger Safety Coordinator.
I work through the Office of Highway Safety as well.
And I'm here to discuss that.
Obviously, you heard from Cindy a minute ago, who's very knowledgeable in the biomechanics of it as far as injury goes and so on.
And you'll hear more testimony on that as well, because our youngest children are the most vulnerable when it comes to crashes and G-forces and so on.
New Hampshire has a pretty robust child passenger safety program.
I'm very proud to say we've got 224 certified technicians statewide, another 11 instructors, and 56 fitting stations throughout the state to help parents and caregivers figure out this complicated process of child seats.
And for those of you who have had children and have dealt with child seats, it can be a little overwhelming and a little confusing.
There's a lot of information there.
And we all know as average individuals, when there's a big instruction book on something, we tend to wing it first and then maybe go back to the instruction manual later.
Why this bill is so important is that this will add consistency to the best practice message that we put out, as well as the American Academy of Pediatrics in how best to care for these vulnerable young children.
It's very important that these kids remain rear-facing.
The obstacle that we have as as technicians in educating is that new parents want to see the faces of these beautiful little babies they now have.
And I understand that.
It's understandable that they would want to look at their baby in the rearview mirror.
However, that really makes those children extremely vulnerable in the event of a crash.
So the best practice is to keep kids rear facing as long as possible.
And there's a lot of good equipment out there now that will allow parents to do that.
As long as they know, they're expected to keep those kids rear facing.
There's child seats out there now that go rear facing up to anywhere between 40 and 50 pounds and are getting more and more common so that emphasizes the need to keep kids rear facing because the industry is changing to do that as well so i thank you very much for your consideration for this bill again i'm in favor of this bill i feel the children of new hampshire will benefit greatly from this bill and I would be happy to answer any questions for you at this time.
Any questions from the table?
Seeing none, thank you sir.
Thank you.
Before you do leave though, I've got two, I've got a Thomas Leach and a Tom Leach.
Could there be two?
Or did you maybe sign up twice inadvertently?
I guess I lost him.
Sorry, I removed him before you said that.
I just had him back.
Well, maybe you can help me out too.
I see two Tom Leaches on our sheet.
I just want to make sure I'm not ignoring them if I continue.
It's quite possible that there was a double sign up.
Sorry about that.
Yeah, I don't see.
Different email addresses, but that's why I wanted to clarify.
All right, we'll go with it.
Thank you, sir.
Chair recognizes Captain Haynes from the Department of Safety are in support of the Good afternoon, sir.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chairman, members, representatives.
I'm not going to echo everything everybody said.
The Office of Highway Safety and Department of Safety are in support of this bill.
It is one of the primary goals of the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration to get more people in rear-facing seats and more people to buckle up all throughout the car.
So therefore, we just want to voice that we are really, really, really in support of this bill to ensure that the safety of our very young adults, our very young children, I should say, and infants are protected on our highways.
Thank you.
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you, sir.
As we move our way down the list here, Chair recognizes Colella, representing Juvenile Product Manufacturers Association, opposed to the bill.
Can I get that first name again?
Sorry.
Joseph Colella.
I see him on the screen.
I see him on the attendance.
Yeah, I just promoted him.
Sorry about that.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me now?
Good afternoon.
Strangely, my screen changed.
I do want to clarify before I start.
I'm Joe Colella, the director of child passenger safety for the Juvenile Products Manufacturers Association, that conceptually we support this bill.
I know I'm listed as opposition.
We support this bill conceptually.
Our concern is just about some of the wording.
And just to tell you how much I support it, I've been an instructor and have worked with some of your, with Tom Leach and with Cindy Tuttle for many years, trying to educate people on the importance of child passenger safety.
So today I'm representing the Juvenile Products Manufacturers Association.
We appreciate Chairman Walsh and Transportation Committee the opportunity to testify on House Bill 251.
We're a not-for-profit trade organization representing 95% of the prenatal to preschool industry, including the producers, the importers, and distributors of a broad range of child care articles, including car seats.
And we exist to advance the interests and the growth and the well-being of the industry.
As your committee considers the improved child occupant protection legislation for New Hampshire families, the JPMA would like to support the effort and to help assure consistency with the latest research and the current recommendations.
And I know you're already on that path because I've heard your testimony.
I've read your bill.
The updated policy statements from both the American Academy of Pediatrics and the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration recommend delaying transition to the next type of restraint.
So forward-facing for as long as possible based on the specific weight, height, and age limits in the manufacturer instructions for the specific car seat model.
And as Tom Leach already mentioned, we're seeing more car seats that are coming out that go to higher weights rear facing.
We generally support that expansion, but when you choose an age as the requirement, like age two is currently chosen, we have to consider that these are safety devices and that they're designed and tested to protect children within specified height and range.
I'm sorry, height and weight ranges when they're used correctly.
And for that reason, what we're strongly recommending is specifying that the child restraint manufacturer instructions for height, weight, age, and usage must be followed, and that the requirement not only be applied to children underage too, but that same requirement, the manufacturer's instructions for height, weight, age, and usage need to apply to all children, regardless of the type of restraint that they're that they're writing it.
To further assist with that, I, with our written testimony, I sent some model language that JPMA worked on with experts in the field that's already been endorsed by Safe Kids Worldwide and the Safe States Alliance because they agree with it.
And basically what it does is it takes the American Academy of Pediatrics recommendations and converts them into what could be legislative requirements.
So that's our biggest concern is making sure that there's full deference to manufacturers instructions and the limitations of the specific models.
Also, separately, on the topic of New Hampshire child restraint legislation, I do want to take the opportunity to express J.P.
May's concern with a New Hampshire OHRV operations law.
of New Hampshire child restraint legislation.
I do wanna take the opportunity to express JPMA's concern with a New Hampshire OHRV operations law that improperly requires the child restraint certified for use in motor vehicles are used by OHRV child occupants.
Child restraint manufacturer instructions do not provide for that.
They do not authorize such use.
And we know that it's good intention that that's been done, but chowder strains and booster seats are designed and tested in accordance with federal regulations and not for the OHRV environment.
Unlike cars, vans, SUVs, and light trucks, OHRVs lack protective systems that include regulated attachment systems for attaching the car seat to the vehicle and other required safety features that supplement the protection offered by the car seat itself.
So we strongly recommend revising that law and eliminating the requirement for using conventional child restraints outside of their instructions, outside of what's allowed by their manufacturers.
So with that, I'll conclude and I'm happy to answer any questions at all on child restraint from the JPMA perspective or from an advocate perspective.
I've been an advocate for 26 years.
Thank you, sir.
Have you reached out to the prime sponsor possibly of some of these suggested changes?
I do remember when we dealt with this a few years ago, I think it was the height and weight versus the age that was the problem for us extending this to and under.
I think that's why we left it alone at the time.
So if there's some, without getting into today, if there's some suggestions.
Yeah, we did send a letter to the original sponsor.
And we were happy to further consult.
We also sent our model language to the original sponsor and to the committee.
I don't know.
Thank you, sir.
I do have a couple of questions.
One's from Representative Hill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
and thank you for taking my question.
I'm wondering if your organization has ever considered model legislation or supported the idea of school buses being fitted with rear-facing seats.
That's an interesting question.
At this point, our organization has not weighed in on that.
And that's primarily because at this point, the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration does not have systems in place that would allow for the attachment of rear-facing car seats.
But that is definitely something that we would look at as an organization in the most favorable light possible if there were such requirements for school buses.
Thank you.
Representative Sykes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Kallala, for taking my question.
The concern or confusion that I'm having is how do we deal with manufacturers who may not belong to your association, who may develop seats that don't meet standards, and how do we then give parents guidance even when they buy, if you will, non-compliant seats?
And that's an excellent question.
First of all, all car seats that are certified for use as child restraints in the United States have to meet Federal Motor Vehicle Safety Standard No.
213, and that's through the Highway Traffic Safety Administration.
There are some non-compliant devices, some alternative designs that have been made, but your law, because it requires the ones that meet the federal standard, your current law, already disallows those car seats.
As far as membership goes, there are two or three car seat manufacturers, legitimate car seat manufacturers, that are not currently part of our organization, but they have to meet Federal Motor Vehicle Safety Standard Number 213.
So they still meet all of the requirements.
Again, the importance in this context is that the limitations for the height, weight, and ages set by the manufacturers can't be superseded by a state law.
It used to be, we could just say properly used, and that meant according to the manufacturer's instructions.
But as laws become rightfully more prescriptive, adding in an age minimum, then they have to also clarify that the car seat still has to be used the way it was designed to be used, the way it's been tested to be used.
So within specific weight ranges and age ranges, height ranges.
Does that make sense?
Well, I appreciate you taking a stab at the answer.
I'm not sure that it completely clarifies my puzzlement, but thank you for that attempt.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just to clarify, it's not JPMA that sets the standards.
Our members all meet the standards set forth by NHTSA.
And non-members who sell car seats in New Hampshire still have to meet those same NHTSA requirements.
The non-compliant seats are normally counterfeit seats.
They're coming from other countries.
And those do not necessarily meet the NHTSA standards.
And those would also not meet your law because your law specifies only car seats that meet the standards.
I guess my concern, I'm going to use, if I may, Mr.
Chairman, with a follow-up.
Thank you, sir.
Just as an analogy of what I'm struggling with.
So I spent decades being a fire prevention officer.
And every smoke detector manufactured in the United States legitimately comes with manufacturers guidelines on how to install them.
But people invariably look to the laws to know how they should do that and very rarely read the manufacturer's instructions.
And so I wonder if there isn't a dual role here that we need to be mindful of.
I don't expect you to respond to that, but that's where my thinking is going.
Yeah.
And I'm going to respond to it anyway, if you don't mind, if you give me 30 seconds.
We agree that there's definitely a role in state legislation for further prescribing and that age too, we fully support it.
We like that because there are car seat manufacturers that allow for it.
And biomechanically, rear facing is safer.
That's what all of the research is showing us.
So we appreciate that.
But you can't use a car seat that has a limit of 22 pounds on it for a 35 pound two-year-old and still expect it to perform adequately in the event of a crash.
You have to make sure you also follow the limitations put on that child restraint by the manufacturer.
Who was it designed for?
So yes, we agree that New Hampshire should pursue this rear-facing to age two, but specify in there, express in there that the manufacturer's instructions for weight, height, age, and usage must also be followed in that process.
You have to get the right car seat for your kid and the kid's size, basically.
Thank you very much.
Sure.
So that raises a question with me, so I'm going to take this one.
Okay.
You mentioned, that's a good question.
You just mentioned that there are certain seats that have certain weight limitations, and you think it's somehow legislatively possible for us to make sure that people are using the right seat for the right kid in each car.
Can you send us examples, possibly, of the different products and how they're rated, and just a little more information on the products themselves?
Yeah, there's an excellent resource list that I can point you to, and I can send you the link to it, But it's put out by the American Academy of Pediatrics.
And basically, it categorizes all rear-facing car seats.
And it tells you the height and the weight limits set by the manufacturer for each model.
Each model has its own height limits and weight limits.
Some of them start where the maximum weight of a child riding rear-facing could be 22 pounds.
And other ones, as Tom Leach mentioned, go all the way up to 50 pounds in that same rear-facing mode.
It's just a question of the materials and the designs and the testing that has been done on the specific model.
So I'd be happy to send you, if that's what would help you, Mr.
Chairman, the list of all the cars that there are and what their height and weight limits are, just so you can also include in your wording, as many other states have already done, that you have to follow the manufacturer's instructions in addition to the age that we've prescribed.
Thank you.
Send me what you can.
But you are certainly refreshing my memory.
Thank you for that.
Representative, I don't know who was first.
Representative Aaron.
Can you put my hand down?
I'm sorry.
Okay, there was a mistake.
Representative Talersky.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
I tracked down on my email the email from JPMA, which was sent January 29th.
So I think I had to go back and refresh my memory because it had been a while.
And I'm looking at your suggested verbiage here on what you recommend.
And it's quite extensive the way it goes through each age requirement and how you do it.
I'm curious, is this wording from a certain state?
Is this just a suggestion?
Or is there a state in particular who actually has nailed it and has the verbiage that you'd like to see in terms of the suggested manufacturer usage?
Excellent question.
The verbiage is actually because so many states moved since 2015, when the American Academy of Pediatrics first changed their recommendations to include age two.
there have been 16 states that have passed laws that require that.
And each one of those laws has its own way of doing that, some of them more effectively than others, so that they're representing not only the child needs and the overall desire, the concept of rear-facing longer, but also the manufacturer's instructions.
What we saw, And this was in consultation with the president of Safe Kids Worldwide and their staff, as an example, the director of the Safe States Alliance, we saw providing guidance to states of wording, model wording, could assist in that.
Right now, we're talking about changing your existing law.
So basically putting a band-aid or putting an extension onto your existing legal wording.
The model law is if you saw a fit to actually replace your law, and it breaks down every age, it just takes the American Academy of Pediatrics recommendations.
There's no editorial content in it.
It takes the American Academy of Pediatrics and puts it in a form that could be enforceable requirements for state legislation.
And that's why we worked with leading advocate organizations like Safe Kids Worldwide and Safe States Alliance to come up with it jointly.
The closest state that has passed something close to it, there's one slight difference because it happened during the drafting of the wording that you're looking at, is Louisiana.
That's the closest to having the prescriptive wording.
They passed it in, I believe, in June of 2019.
So it's not exact, but it's very close in the requirements.
We've, most states that we deal with, that we, that we work with are really looking at that, taking the existing legislation and making a couple of changes to it, as opposed to replacing it with model wording.
So it's really a question of what your committee desires to do with it.
If you want to replace your entire law, that wording would be more representative of the current recommendations than just making slight changes, slight modifications to your existing law.
Does that make sense?
Thank you.
Yes, thank you very much.
Further questions from the committee?
See none.
Thank you, sir.
Okay, thank you very much.
Further questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you, sir.
Okay, thank you.
That's everybody I've got signed up in advance to speak.
Who do we have in the queue, Representative O'Hara?
The sponsor of the bill has his hand up again.
Excuse me?
The sponsor has his hand up.
Oh, as a question?
Representative Donovan Benton has his hand up.
Let's see it.
Do we still have, was it for the previous speaker?
I'm still here.
Okay.
How come I don't have him on my screen?
I just added Ben as a analyst.
Can you hear me?
Okay.
You had a question for Mr.
Colella?
I just wanted to let Mr.
Colella know that I did see his recommendation.
Actually, I just forwarded him the amendment for the bill.
I just had received it today, so he should have that in his inbox about the manufacturer laws amended.
So I just want to let him know that.
Oh, thank you.
Appreciate that.
I will look at it as soon as we get off.
Okay.
Thank you again, sir.
Pleasure.
Thank you.
We have anybody else with their hands raised mr see any on my screen i am seeing none okay okay um what we have these numbers are only inclusive of who signed up in advance as it turns out for this bill they're pretty accurate in support of the bill signed up in advance.
As it turns out for this bill, they're pretty accurate.
In support of the bill, signed up in advance, including the people that spoke, 58.
Opposed, three.
And again, all these records are available if you need to see them later on.
With that, I'll close the public hearing on House Bill 251.
Just a couple of notes before we go.
I wanna thank everybody.
We're actually moving right along through our bills.
There were, like I said earlier, a couple I was hoping to exec today, but no big deal.
We're gonna have plenty of time in the following weeks.
Next week, I don't know if you've seen the calendar yet.
I scheduled a pretty healthy morning with some good bills and an afternoon full of exec session, which will get us somewhat caught up.
We won't get all of them, but getting closer.
The following week, I have not been able to schedule yet.
I'm still waiting to get my day, but I'm actually going to be seeking a second day for next week, the following week.
I still want to make sure that we dispose of all our bills comfortably before the deadline of March 11th.
So as soon as I know if that's a possibility, I will let you all know.
I just want to give you an early heads up that we actually kind of have to.
We've got 32 bills to take care of in a short amount of time.
So it's not unusual to see a second day once in a while.
Thank you.
actually kind of have to.
We're 32 bills to take care of in a short amount of time.
So it's not unusual to see a second day once in a while.
We're putting it up, but it's going to have to happen.
Any questions from the committee for the good of the cause?
Representative Lennie.
I'm just looking at the calendar.
So our next day that's scheduled is next Friday the 19th.
The following week we're in session the 24th and the 25th.
So are you saying you want to meet that week two days, two extra days?
You're right, you're right.
So my apologies.
I was forgetting about session days.
You know what?
That's a great point.
After two days in session, let's see what even the Friday is going to look like.
There's good chance now looking at it that way that we just might wait until the following week and do a double day then again i can't do this in advance only because i don't get to create the schedule of the rooms but uh let me as soon as i know i'll let you all know thanks for bringing that point up thank you anybody else see none have a great afternoon thanks everybody I'll let you all know.
Thanks for bringing that point up.
Thank you.
Anybody else?
Seeing none, have a great afternoon.
Thanks everybody.
Thank you.